James is wild,
man.
You don't understand and you're still
getting late.
It's crazy.
You are three,
one with live.
Got To change subjects had abandoned all
that crazy talk.
We just,
it was,
it was definitely good talk.
Um,
first of all is good to see you.
Great having.
You do too.
I haven't seen it since king queens
spent a long time and um,
I found out about,
you know,
the whole scientology.
I knew you were into it back then,
but it was one of those things where I'd
heard about it and then I met you.
I'm like,
oh,
it's pretty fucking normal.
Intel wants to.
And I send the same thing,
like pretty normal.
Kelly Preston is pretty normal.
She was normal,
you know,
it's,
I guess you get deeper,
get to know them really well and it
might get a little weird because the
thing is scientologist are good people.
They really are.
They really as I did,
believed that we were doing amazing
things for the world.
So they go into it thinking I'm helping
myself,
I'm helping others.
Um,
but then as you,
like you said,
as you get more and more,
uh,
and by the way you don't really get
close to something intelligent when
you're assigned to help,
like when you're,
when you're not in scientology is
correct.
Like everything that I did and they do
is for the purpose of setting a good
example,
being a good person,
being a good friend.
Um,
so to get you in because Dr does a
purpose and that like I would never tell
when I was in a non scientologists my
real problems.
It would be kind of a bad for the church
to ever appear human to a non
scientologists it'd be setting a bad
example.
Like it would actually be considered
like a transgression if I told you joe,
you know,
Oh yeah,
I'm fighting with my mother and fighting
with my husband or I would never tell
you those types of things because it
would be bad pr for the church.
Wow.
So that's something that you're taught.
Correct.
Now you,
you kinda grew up in it.
Yes.
How old were you when you?
Nine.
I think when my mother married,
remember precise intelligence a little
bit and you know,
what I remember precise Intelligi was,
you know,
I had a very Catholic Sicilian father
who believed in punishment,
believed in not toe.
Did I talk to you?
I don't know what you're talking to me
like that kind of guy,
right?
Like my dad says that the head of the
table and then we don't talk back at all
or you know,
so that is kind of what I knew and then
we were baptized as Catholics because my
mother wasn't really religious.
My mother is Jewish,
she's,
you know,
so she,
but she didn't have any kind of religion
growing up.
My father of course was Catholic,
so we got baptized as Catholics and the
only time we really went to churches
with our grandma,
we went to visit her in,
you know,
in the city and my dad on holidays.
So,
uh,
that's really kind of all I remember
precise ontology and my mother meeting,
my Stepdad,
he was in scientology and he got her in
as well.
US,
like right away,
right away.
Yes.
Part of the deal,
correct.
Yeah.
And by the way,
Joe,
like we went from like,
don't talk until you're spoken to,
to hey,
we see you as spiritual beings.
We want you to talk to us.
We want you to communicate like you're
just,
you're not,
you're not children,
your,
you know,
spirits in a little body.
And so immediately that kind of
indoctrination begins that you're not a
child.
And so,
you know,
as children,
you have kids,
you know,
they always want to be grown up so that,
that really starts to work.
This kind of idea that you're an
elitist,
that your,
your ego becomes kind of stroked as a
kid.
Like you're very powerful and you
returned and you came back and you found
yourself back.
You picked your mother because you knew
she'd get into scientology and you're
very strongly and you're very strong.
Nicole,
to my sister,
you picked your mother.
You've picked your mother for this
reason,
to find your way back to scientology.
Now as a child,
remember you,
you want to be more important than you
are.
Kids are always trying to exercise their
power,
you know?
So that speaks to something inside of
you that like,
oh,
I'm bigger than a kid,
I'm more than a kid.
I'm a spiritual being in a little body.
And so it sets up that kind of
indoctrination very early on.
Did you like it because it made you,
when you were young that made you feel
like,
okay,
now I can express myself better.
I don't feel suppressed.
Yes,
exactly.
Because again,
I'm going from a dad who's tells me to
shut the F up and walk when I talk to
you and you sit in that chair and you
don't have any thoughts worth listening
to,
to.
You're very much a,
an important being.
You're a big being.
That's a word that's used a lot.
Those words,
big beings,
your big being.
Um,
and so yes,
you start to feel very important.
You start to feel,
um,
that you're powerful.
These are not bad things to make kids
feel,
but this is the way colts work and you
don't realize that Joe,
until you're out,
you don't realize any of this was really
going on because I've heard people call
it a cold throughout my 30 plus years
and I was offended by it.
I was deeply offended by it and I
couldn't even allow myself to believe
that I was in a cult.
And so all these epiphany's are only
happening after the fact while I was
watching the scholarly documentary once
on Christianity and they were referring
to it as the cult of Christianity.
And um,
it's the word is the correct word and if
you want to just look at it in terms of
the actual literal definition of it,
but it's automatically got this negative
connotation to the word called brainwash
or lost.
But there,
there's a,
there's a inclination that people have
to be tribal.
There's a natural inclination.
People have to be on a team.
And we like it when we're all together.
I know you're a scientologist,
I'm a scientologist.
We're together in this thing.
Everybody else doesn't get it right.
And that's,
that's a good feeling,
right?
And you're taught that you are taught
that you are the elite of the world by
the way you're going in every single
day.
It's not like I'm going,
I'm going Easter and I'm going
Christmas.
You know,
it's an every dayness.
So what did you do every day?
Like when you say you went into real
life,
do king of Queens and then after
rehearsal I'd have to drive to Hollywood
and put in my two and a half hours a
day.
Two and a half hours every day?
Yeah,
every minimum.
Minimum.
Okay.
So then if I couldn't like let's say on
a tape day,
I couldn't,
you know,
it was there from nine in the morning
until 10 at night.
Asian know I'd have to make up the time
on the weekends or I'd have to make up
time on my hiatus.
So I'd be there all day and night.
If you went to Hawaii on vacation or
something very rare that scientologist
we're going to vacation.
I'd have to make up the time.
I'd have to make up the time when I got
back,
I'd have to put in on weekends,
like let's say if my schedule was,
you know,
12 to 2:30
to go in and I'd have to go in one to
six or one to 10 or nine to 10.
So there's an everydayness of this
indoctrination.
It's not only that there's this
policies,
right?
You're studying the policies all day and
all night you're looking up words you
don't understand.
You're being tested.
Like after you read an l,
Ron Hubbard,
l,
Ron Hubbard policy,
then you're tested,
you go into another room and they go,
what is the definition of this?
What is the definition of that?
So it's,
it's almost worse.
Uh,
we had a cult expert on and he said,
it's worse.
I entered the doors because you actually
brainwash yourself because you have to
study the policies of the church and
then you get tested on it and you have
to look up words you don't understand.
You have to put them in sentences.
You have to write essays,
you have to do clay demonstrations.
So you're really brainwashing yourself
and you're speaking all the same
language,
you're all working towards one goal and
that is very intoxicated like it is to
feel like you're saying,
to be tribal,
to be part of something.
Imagine being something part of
something that you think and and are
told and are reading every day is the
most important thing.
That's gonna.
Save mankind.
You are doing the work that no other
group is doing and so you believe that
you start.
You want to believe that you want to
believe I'm more than just an actress.
I'm more than just this,
I'm saving the planet.
And now all this stuff that you're
doing,
you're going in for two and a half hours
every day.
Are you trying to move your way up the
ranking system?
Because there's a chart,
right?
And everybody's a well,
there's like a.
The indoc like the little courses,
they're called self improvement courses
and these are the things that I,
people like me would say,
like when people would ask me about the
money,
right?
I said,
well,
there's courses for $35,
$65.
You know,
it's all it,
it's very affordable like these,
these are the lines that were taught to
say it's not an outright lie,
it's,
it's omitting a lot of data,
right?
Because really the next,
the followup to that is,
but when you're really a scientology,
it's going to cost you half a million
easy or whatever it's going to be,
but it's preset prices.
So you start on these self improvement
courses and then you get onto this
actual chart called the bridge.
And the bridge is very precise.
Nobody's doing different things.
We're all working at the bottom all the
way up to the top,
which was ot eight.
That's like the most enlightened.
So how many people were Ota?
Uh,
not a lot anymore because the people who
were in scientology and the fifties,
sixties,
and seventies who got to Ota,
uh,
we're like,
this is some bullshit.
It wasn't what I thought it was going to
be.
And so a lot of them left at a time.
I'm sure scientology was big because it
was almost,
it almost spoke to the time that it was,
you know,
when people wanted free thinking,
but also wanted to be morally on the
right path,
you know,
not on drugs,
like they were,
you know,
maybe not part of that,
but they,
they kind of didn't want to be held by
a,
you know,
a certain,
a religion,
but they did still wants virtuality and
their life and I think it spoke to the
people of the time.
Um,
so I don't think you're,
you're going to find new scientologists
in the world.
The Internet took a big chunk out of
that.
Yes.
Because of the information.
Information was very hard to get a,
for example.
Oh yeah.
For example,
let's say you are scientologists and um,
one day I just didn't see you.
And I said,
hey,
what happened to Joe?
Where's Joe?
Why is he not in scientology anymore?
Oh,
they,
they tell me whatever they want to tell
me about you to discredit you.
He's an enemy to the church and here are
the reasons why.
And they could say anything.
And they do say anything that
immediately makes me not want to talk to
you ever again.
The common enemy,
an enemy.
Once you're an enemy,
I can't actually talk to you.
The policy says that once you are
declared labeled a suppressive person,
my association with you would then make
me a suppressive person and then me and
enemy so I can't actually talk to you,
but they can tell me whatever they want
to tell me about you.
And so I couldn't actually find out are
these things true about joe?
But now with the Internet,
with social media,
it's harder and harder to,
to tell people whatever you want to tell
them about the person because the
information is there.
You have to want to seek it out.
I didn't seek it out.
Um,
I didn't want to seek it out.
And when I did seek it out and I'd go to
the church,
they'd say,
that's a lie.
That's not true.
Here's the real data.
And they have actual doctored,
you know?
Um,
it,
it actually doctor things that make you
believe,
I mean,
you don't,
you're not going to go and take it to an
analyst,
you're not going to take it to somebody
and go,
is this a real document?
Um,
you,
you tend to believe the church you're in
and raised in most of your life now.
It had to have been positive in some way
for you,
of course,
gave you some confidence.
It gave you a true belief in yourself
that you are on the right path.
Because I had seen some interviews with
you where you were talking about it when
you were in it and you genuinely seem to
believe that it was very beneficial to,
of course there's basic morals and basic
tools to help you in your life.
But remember it wasn't educated.
Most scientologists are not educated.
And so as far as a college education,
any education?
Yeah,
I left school in the eighth grade.
Really?
Scientology does not value a traditional
education.
They value your education in high
school.
Never.
Whoa.
How old were you?
I don't know how old you and Heisler.
I don't even know the eighth graders.
Like 13 I think.
Right.
So when you were 13 you just stopped
going to school,
stopped going to school and I was doing
scientology and I was working like
literally working,
selling car insurance and you were
working at 13 or scientology companies
and so was my sister.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
and people ask like,
well,
how come the,
uh,
nobody did anything.
How come child protective services,
who's calling them who saying and not to
mention where are then aligning.
Our parents are lying saying they're
getting a private education,
they're getting tutored at home or
they're going to a scientology school,
which is partially true or I,
yeah,
I got my ged.
So I did things like that to,
to um,
but the,
the original question was what was the,
because it was about me learning what it
was about late.
What was your original question?
Because I was answering,
it had to be of some benefit to you
because it gave me confidence because I
thought I was getting,
you know,
I'm looking at these big words.
I'm using a dictionary.
I'm like,
you're doing more school than you
could've ever imagined.
Even as you know,
and,
and you,
um,
I started to feel like,
oh,
I'm,
I'm really accomplishing something.
I'm so,
yes,
there are benefits to it,
but I didn't realize because I was a kid
that the things you're talking about
that were beneficial in the real world,
I thought they were.
They were invented by Elbert Hubbard as
most people do believe that.
So you're saying where these things are
beneficial.
I would have learned these things as
Sunday school.
I would have learned these things about
being a good human being,
being around other people,
but regardless if I was brainwashed into
believing that I was doing great things
and learning great things and that does
work.
You know what I mean?
It,
it does work.
If I say,
Hey Joe,
if you do these steps,
these take these steps and you really
truly believe in me,
you can then attributed to Leah.
You can say Lhi as an amazing life
coach.
She told me to do these things and
without her I can't.
You know what I'm saying it,
but not knowing that it was available to
me in the real world because I didn't.
I thought I'll.
Ron Hubbard had come up with these
things.
Now.
When did it start to unravel for you?
Well,
it's a,
it's,
it wasn't just one thing.
I think people always think what was the
one.
It wasn't just one thing was just,
it was six years of me basically.
I was like begging them for these things
not to be true that I was hearing about
like what it was.
For example,
when I went to Tom Cruise's wedding and
I saw the leader's wife wasn't there and
the,
you know,
David Miscavige,
who's the head of the Church of
Scientology,
uh,
his wife wasn't there.
And when I asked the question and I
said,
where is shelly?
Why is his assistant here?
I'm scattered people to scattered.
And then I was told I didn't have the F
and rank to be asking about a human
about the leader's wife.
It wasn't that she was just an average
person that I didn't have the rank to
ask about the rank,
the rank.
Wow.
And so that,
that would be okay.
That was the beginning.
But then when I went to my friends now
w,
W,
when you're my friend,
I consider you family.
Like I really do.
I take my friends very seriously.
And um,
my friends have 35 years.
You're looking at my sex meet nails
right now.
You're wanting my sexy nails.
You do a very nice nails.
You didn't use the word sexy though,
you said Nice.
You know,
I'm different than other people when it
comes to nails apparently.
Because now when you say real,
what does that mean?
Glued on?
No,
they're not going to know that I'm
appreciating the more.
Okay.
We're finding out a lot about you.
I'd like to do a whole couple of hours
with you talking about other things.
You have to hold onto cans and you don't
have to hold on cans,
but you do have to wear Cologne because
Cologne wearing.
Okay.
You're too cute.
Um,
so.
Okay.
So let me get back.
What was I saying?
David miscavige.
You have the right to question.
Yeah.
But then seeing my friends' reaction to
it where I said,
what you need to get involved in this,
I think there's something really off
with David Ms Dot.
Well,
I didn't know what was going on.
I saw Tom have an executive role in our
church,
which had a problem with.
Because remember,
uh,
you learned very early on what l Ron
Hubbard says is the law.
There's no,
um,
it,
it's not up for interpretation.
There's no assimilation of data.
It's just what it says.
It's not what Joe thinks over.
Ron Hubbard said what Leah things.
It's what it says.
And it's very strict.
It's always,
what does ela reach say?
Read it again.
What does it say?
And it's very tough.
So I was very by
the book person.
I'm a by the book person.
Okay.
If I have a recipe,
I followed exactly.
I don't do pinches and I'm doing that
shit.
I do exactly how it says in the recipe.
And then I see how it goes into that.
Scientology is about word for word.
What does it say?
My understanding and the policy is there
is no celebrity that should be treated
any differently than any parishioner,
and I was seeing behavior and I was
seeing things that wouldn't be okay,
that are not okay for the average
parishioner,
but we're being made to be okay for Tom
and it didn't matter to me that he was
taught to me.
I saw him as a team member in the Church
of Scientology and we were working on
the same thing.
Um,
I actually thought I was a better
example of scientology than he was and I
wrote reports on him,
like internal reports on him,
which I didn't realize we're kind of
getting me a to be a target for the
church,
but I didn't realize his position in the
church.
You wrote internal reports?
Yes.
We're all required to write reports on
each other.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
There's a policy.
There's a policy about writing reports.
So if I,
let's say you and I are scientologist.
Okay.
You and I go out one night,
like not like that Joe.
So don't get it.
You seem uncomfortable.
No,
no,
no.
You did it because he said Nice as
opposed to that you said Nice,
nice,
nice.
I said,
I think I probably on my sexy nails.
He said they're nice.
They're nice.
They're beautiful.
Suck better.
Okay.
If you wore Cologne,
I feel like you'd have better
adjectives.
Okay.
I'm like,
are you a fine guy when your wife comes
out as,
as I look Jodie,
you say,
fine.
No,
you look great.
You say great.
Beautiful.
Lovely.
It's very clinical.
You have kid comes from I think
different adjectives.
Different words have different meanings
depending on who,
what person they come from and how the
person with the intent behind it.
Well,
beautiful.
You look beautiful.
I Dunno,
I guess.
Yeah.
I mean evangelists says I looked
beautiful.
Let's go back to the internal reports on
topic,
so yeah,
so let's say you go,
you and I went out.
We were just went out one night.
We were going out for dinner,
a group of us and something and I saw
you doing something that's not for the
book.
I have to write a report.
I read aloud to drink.
Not really,
no.
Okay.
What if I got lit up?
Um,
I'd probably write a report and say,
come on,
fuck it.
LRH would love it.
I.
Okay.
I said yes.
So then I write a report on you.
And I said Joe was acting inappropriate.
He was making fun of l Ron Hubbard
because you're not allowed to joke and
degrade Ron Hubbard as a policy called
joker's integrators and integrators.
Yes.
You and I would be very much I've been,
yes.
Have you been in trouble for that many
times.
Okay.
So I would have to write a report.
It's go writing you up.
I'd have to write you up because let's
say you went into like the next day for
a session and you said,
and they said,
you know,
they do the check,
they do a check on you every day.
Um,
do you have an upset?
Do you have a present time problem or
are you withholding anything?
Now,
if you were a real swing intelligence,
you would know that you probably
shouldn't be drinking and carrying on
because of a 24 hour rule.
You can't drink 24 hours before you're
going to be doing a service.
Remember,
you're required to go in every day so
you never can drink.
Right.
And if you do,
you consider it a transgression.
So that's on your mind that you're
withholding this information.
Now,
if you went on a vacation and you knew
that you were going to make it up when
you got back?
Yeah,
that's okay because you're not going in
because you're not going in.
Okay.
That's the only time then.
Correct.
Or if you're just not getting a service,
but that's if you're not going to
correct.
So you go in and you'd say,
okay,
so I went out last night,
I ordered a bunch of shots and I made a
comment about to l Ron Hubbard or
whatever,
and they go,
okay,
great.
When was it?
Who would you do it with?
Who was there?
They write down all the names.
It's also being recorded and they're
writing everything down.
Who knew about it will be the next
question.
Who knew about it?
You'd say,
well,
Leah was there.
They go.
Leo was there.
Okay,
interesting.
Then that is going to write.
Leah knew about it and didn't do
anything about it.
Then I'd get pulled in.
Why didn't you write a report on Joe?
Because Joe just admitted that he was
drinking and carrying on and you didn't
write him up.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So it creates that kind of environment.
So it's a rat environment.
Correct.
So I was.
I was writing up Tom and I was writing
up David,
Ms Dot Gavin.
What did you write up,
Tom,
for jumping on couches and being
inappropriate.
I thought he was being inappropriate.
Jumping on couches for when he did
Oprah.
I thought it was a bad example that also
wrote up John for for the battlefield
earth.
I thought it was for the movie itself.
First of all,
that movie was awesome.
If you haven't seen battlefield earth,
it's one of my favorite.
Unintentional.
He would joke.
No,
it was terrible.
Yeah,
but awesome.
Because it's so terrible.
Ridiculous.
Terrible becomes good.
It crosses over that.
It does.
After a while.
You're right.
It does,
yeah.
What's that movie with the dancing one
with Elizabeth Berkley showgirls,
showgirls,
showgirls.
Yes.
That's the best one.
Yeah.
That's probably the terrible movie
becomes awesome because it's so bad.
You're like,
what in the fuck were they doing?
And it's fantastic.
You're like,
yes,
I can feel the earth is right up there.
Right.
So I did things like that.
I'm not that.
I was a great example,
nor am I a great example,
but I wrote a whole thing about him
jumping up on Oprah's couch,
but I also listen.
I gave myself up.
I know I was writing,
I was writing myself up.
I was reading my mother up,
I was writing my husband and he jumped
up on Oprah's couch because he was in
love,
right?
Supposedly,
you know,
he jumped up,
they told me,
they pulled me in and they said,
you know,
could it be that you're just not as high
on the scale like in life,
like you're.
So basically they were saying like,
you're a bitch so you can't understand.
You can understand that kind of love
because I was like all,
I guess because I've been married 20
years.
I don't understand jumping on account,
but I thought it was a.
It wasn't a good example because because
I cared so much about my church and the
work that we were doing and I didn't
want the church to be seen as a joke,
or it's or one of its senior members,
which he's considered a senior.
Scientologist thought it was
inappropriate.
It was out of line.
I just wanted him.
Right.
I mean,
listen,
I'm not perfect.
I mean,
of course there's many things that would
be considered a bad example in my every
day.
I'm not a great example.
Um,
but at the time I thought I was pretty
pristine.
But looking at it now,
you feel like it's totally innocuous.
He's just on a couch jumping around
having a good time.
Yes.
But if you knew how serious scientology
was about clearing the planet,
it did not go with our intentions and
our goals.
Um,
so anyway,
I was writing him up and I was writing
everybody up and I was writing everybody
up at the wedding because I thought our
senior executives were.
And I was like,
wiring them back from Italy,
from my hotel room,
uh,
calling one of my closest friends who
was a scientologist and I'm like,
and then I need you to write this.
I need you to write this verbatim.
I need you to write this verbatim and I
need you to get this to the watchdog
committee.
And I think I took frantic.
I was frantic and I was heartbroken
because it's like seeing if you believe
that the sea organization and the people
at the higher,
you know,
that our senior executive Strada of your
church are living a pristine and perfect
life that you're trying to aspire to,
that you're spending your day and night
and money and time like you.
This is what we're trying to be.
And I'm seeing not great examples of
what this is now.
Like it seemed behind the curtain.
I was like,
I don't want to see this.
And I really thought I was going to save
the church.
I thought my writing reports,
it's like I'm going to take over the
church and I'm going to get it right by
l,
Ron Hubbard.
I really still believe in the policies
of l Ron Hubbard.
I just believe they were bending the
rules for celebrity and I was like,
he's a celebrity who gives a shit what
he's doing.
Like he's a scientologist first and a
celebrity second to me,
so that's why it's difficult.
I don't want to talk shit about another
actor because we've all met asshole
actors and we're not really supposed to
be talking about them.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just.
You don't hear that a lot.
You don't hear a lot of actors doing
that to other actors,
but for me it was just a scientologist.
So you take out these reports on him.
I write these reports.
I'm sent to Florida immediately.
The Mecca,
the hub of psychology.
That's right for interrogations.
No,
and I mean like interrogation to fly out
there.
I fly out there.
I'm a in the room.
I'm in a room,
you know,
with cameras,
with my person who is armed with
information,
unbeknownst to me have a stack of
reports that were written on me by
everybody who worked for Tom a stack.
Now,
let me tell you about your report,
so he decided that everyone who works
for him has to take out a report on you.
I don't know what he knew,
but that that is that the church is very
much involved with his life.
He's staffed by people who work for the
church.
No non scientologists works for him,
but it was if you say something bad
about this person,
you were talking about God and you and I
was asked,
you have sexual intentions towards him.
What are your evil intentions towards
him?
David Miscavige?
What are your evil intention towards l
Ron Hubbard and it was three months of
this.
It was and I had to retract everything I
said.
I said I made it all up.
I didn't see any of it to get out of
there,
and so then when I came back to la they
said they want to see you again here in
celebrity center.
So I went to celebrity center and they
said,
look,
everything that was done to you was
wrong.
I was like,
right,
I know that.
We just want to let it go.
You need to let it go because if the
fact that you're not letting go means
that you're guilty of the crimes that
you're saying.
You're saying that everything was wrong.
That was done to you in Florida because
they wanted me to come back because I
was kind of like,
I'm not.
When I came back from Florida is kind of
not really a dedicated scientologist
anymore,
but I wasn't doing anything to rock the
boat with my family.
And how long were you in Florida?
For?
Three months.
Three months of,
of,
of dealing with this every day for three
months.
I had to write apology letters.
So you're there for 90 days?
Tom Cruise during my hiatus and shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what I'm doing most of the time.
And,
and we have a family.
You're married.
My mother was there,
my daughter was there,
my husband was there.
And how much the other day are you
spending all day?
All Day.
Every day.
Did you see defending your life?
No.
Oh God.
You have to see it.
What is it?
It's a movie where Meryl Streep and I
forgot the name anyway,
they die and they go into the,
you know,
the holding cell like where they're
going to decide their fate,
are they going back to Earth which is
considered hell or they going on to
heaven and Meryl Streep lived a pristine
life and they review your life,
right?
And they have judges and everything,
So they review good moments and bad
moments of your life and they decide are
you going to go on,
are you going to go back to hell?
And Meryl Streep was of course pristine,
but then the guy that I keep forgetting
just run and saying,
um,
but you know,
they were looking at times where he
didn't stick up for himself or where he
pussied out of something.
Right?
And so they were judging him pretty
harshly,
right where they were like,
you need to come back in the morning.
And like,
it was like an old day.
Like we're reviewing
a 120 days of your life,
right?
Meryl Streep,
they looked at like five days and
they're like,
don't worry,
just come back when you can.
I was,
that was me,
like my mother was there to do some
fluff thing and she was like,
oh,
come have lunch with me.
And my person was like,
be back in 10 minutes.
You go get a sandwich and eat in the
elevator and you need to be back here in
10 minutes.
It was like,
for me,
it was like defending your life because
my mother was just like,
she had,
she was,
she didn't know what was going on.
She didn't.
You don't usually tell your family what
you're doing.
I wouldn't tell my husband what was
happening to me because I didn't want to
create.
Can you imagine this idea?
Meet your husband in scientology?
No,
my husband was out.
He was never in.
I'm buying him a,
you made him,
made him a scientologist.
Um,
which is good because he was still kind
of cool,
you know what I'm saying?
So he wasn't like,
he was still kind of freaky a little
bit,
you know,
still believed in slapping and ass once
in a while.
So like I kinda got of both worlds.
You can't slap,
you're considered aberrated choking?
Absolutely not.
It would be,
honestly,
you would be considered like you've
really.
There's something really wrong with him,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
no,
I didn't think so.
When you say things like Nice.
Yeah.
Nice.
Anyway,
so you're there for 90 days?
Yeah.
I'm not telling my family when I'm going
through,
I'm not because I don't want to create a
bad situation with the church.
Like how crazy is that reviewing these
papers,
I'm admitting my crimes.
I'm saying maybe I do.
Maybe I do.
Maybe I didn't see what I saw.
These people that you're meeting with in
Florida,
they assign you a person but you hadn't
met them previously.
So just some person with paperwork and
they're going over your.
Well they have you on the meter.
They have you on the lie detector test.
I mean on the line with the cans that
you're talking about.
Yeah.
You're in a room that's locked and
nothing doesn't do anything right that
the meter.
Well,
it does something.
I don't exactly.
I mean there is an actual explanation
for it in the real world.
I'm not smart enough to,
to retell it to you,
but uh,
if I was to have a meter here and you
had a thought I could show you,
it does register that you thought
something but you can't really
differentiate what those thoughts are
not but as.
But as someone who trains in scientology
all you're trained to do,
which what I was doing,
I was training to administer scientology
to people was learning to do that and I
would learn to say,
Joe,
what was that thought?
What was that thought?
I don't know what you're thinking,
but I just know that you had a thought
and so I ask you a question and then I
look at the meter to see that it
registered on the meter and regardless
of what you want to talk about,
we're only going to talk about what I
see on the meter.
And then there's also,
it's open to suggestion,
right?
You could say,
is this a moment where you had doubt?
Is this a moment where you were angry
and then the person has to think,
wow,
was it?
Yeah.
And they start convincing you.
Correct.
Well,
the first thing they do is they.
You need some of your discussing coconut
water or no,
you liked that said are atrocious.
You loved it.
I didn't love it.
I also didn't love your coffee drink,
but I'm sure their sponsors.
I loved everything you had joe,
that this natural stuff you didn't like
everybody.
Everything needs a minute.
There's no sugar.
Wow.
It's pure taste.
The bean you like pure,
pure.
So after this 90 days of being there,
90 days of being stuck in this,
I mean it must be like a management
believe that I was really,
really,
really messed up.
I would imagine too that they have
probably a pretty grand establishment
and clearwater,
right?
It's probably intimidating.
Like that's how a lot of cults and
religions like to rocket it didn't go to
a like a pretty big place.
It's a huge place,
but if you're raised in it and you know
you're,
you're very familiar with it,
but it is when you realize your position
in the church takes a backseat to the
leader and Tom Cruise,
you realized that that was scary to me
because it was against everything you've
been taught.
Everything I've been taught,
everything that had been taught is that
everyone is some sort of a spiritual
being and everyone's equal and then your
whole goal as scientologists act for the
greater good of mankind and sort of
bring as many people into this as you
can because you're going to help them.
Right?
Because it wasn't ever going to get
somebody in because I want to screw with
their lines up.
It was always,
I want to get this person in because I
want them to be happy.
I want them to contribute to what we're
doing.
Now is the thought process that Tom
Cruise being this huge celebrity
worldwide figure that it's very
important to keep him happy and he
probably.
The main goal of scientology is to keep
tom what our ego boost that must be for
him.
Oh,
will see a.
That is something that,
that people say all the time to me like
why is that pot where men,
that ashtray.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
No Joe,
do you know that I've noticed smoked
pot.
Oh you should definitely try it right
now.
I'm scared.
Oh you should be.
Why?
What would happen?
Cause you to start freaking out thinking
about all sorts of stuff.
Yeah.
And so you just keep it dirty like that.
The Ashtray.
What do you mean?
Why don't you make it nice?
Why don't you presented in like,
man,
this is my man cave.
Men will give a fuck about.
Nice.
Yeah.
Well actually I shouldn't have been
surprised hearing what I heard before he
started for you don't try to talk over
each other because you know what I'm
going to say you've never had.
No.
I would suggest like a little tiny
amount for you just because somebody
said something about gummy bears to me
about,
you know,
Jesus,
don't fuck with those gummy bears.
Like powerful.
Those are horrendous.
So what happened?
Anything?
Yeah,
you're on a journey
on your life.
It'll give you extreme paranoia.
You'll start finding,
well it's not,
but when you come out of it it's very
beneficial because you realize that it's
all bullshit and that you were nervous
about some things that it just
highlights your vulnerability that it
takes your blinders away.
That doesn't sound like fun.
Well,
it's not necessarily that fun.
So you wouldn't do it again or.
I do it all the time.
The gummy gummy bears too.
I do them all the time.
You liked that feeling of being?
Yeah,
I think it's good for you.
I think it's good to be vulnerable.
That's good.
It's good to understand.
There's got to be vulnerable.
You're really just this finite organism
floating through infinity,
you know?
I think,
but I feel that way without it.
Okay.
Well then you don't need it.
I mean it's all for everybody.
Oh Wow.
Kind of want to get to push it on me a
little bit and you just gave up.
I think it benefits a lot of people.
It makes you more sensitive.
It gives you a better sense of
community.
It makes you kinder.
I definitely that that.
Yeah.
Okay.
It,
it'll make you a,
a more.
Um,
I think it,
it makes you a more loving person.
I really believe that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Back to what you're saying.
Oh,
it makes sex feel better.
It makes food taste better.
Marry to a Puerto Rican food that you
don't have a little shadow Puerto
Ricans.
They do not have sex.
I can tell you that.
All of them,
I shouldn't say they,
like I've only had sex with one of them.
I'm the celebrity.
Uh,
we all know there's treatment.
Different treatment celebrities.
Well,
especially in scientology,
right?
No,
it's highlighted.
It is like nothing you could ever
imagine it is.
So when people say Tom doesn't leave
because they have information on him or
John,
that's not the reason.
The amount of power they receive from
this church is like nothing in
Hollywood.
It is like nothing.
There is no reason for them to leave
this environment.
Right.
So it's super beneficial for them to be
attached to it.
Correct it as employees,
they work for them.
All these people will take care of his
every need.
Yes.
And there's a policy on how to talk to
somebody like you wouldn't say,
I'm like,
if you said go get me a go get me a
coffee and I wanted this temperature,
there's no,
I can't get it.
We're five miles from any,
you know,
we're 30,
there'll be none of that kind of talk.
Like not any policy about don't you
don't talk back like ever.
You don't step out of line,
you don't give an opinion,
you don't make a face,
you don't make a gesture,
you don't see if you step out of line in
any way you are dealt with by the
church.
So we spent essentially has servants
correct.
How many people?
Like a lot.
A Lot,
a lot.
And by the way,
I don't begrudge.
Somebody would have staff like if you
can have it,
I go do it all day,
all night.
Do it all day,
But when you believe as a scientologist,
you are working for somebody
who single handedly is saving the planet
and you deserve that kind of punishment.
That's something different.
Babe.
You understand what?
Like that?
That's a,
it's an abuse that is not justified,
but it is justified because you believe
that you are single handedly saving the
planet Capeesh Yeah.
No,
I get it.
So,
um,
so he's the main figurehead.
He's the main guy,
like right up with ms dot savage.
Right.
And then John Travolta somewhere in
that,
I think John was given what a,
a designation called Pecan where the
con,
not con,
Con k,
h a k,
h a n Kokona.
He's given this designation of cocoon,
which there's a policy that basically
says you can kill another human being if
you were conned,
you're going to look the other way.
And he was given.
He was given that by Eldorado Hubbard.
Don't we laugh because you don't make me
go.
Please don't make me laugh.
Don't laugh.
Sometimes you work on a car because
first of all,
not very well.
Do you have any takes?
I ruined because of Kevin Goes,
don't don't ruin this.
Take.
I go,
no,
don't tell him you're going to do with
that.
Then I would ruin a gel because he,
he would do some stupid shit with his
hands or something that he never
rehearsed.
That would make me cry from laughter.
Yes,
and he was really highly inappropriate
and moments that made me pee almost.
Yeah.
He's allowed to kill people.
I don't know.
I don't.
I should look at the policy again.
I don't want to us,
we got to put.
You're supposed to look the other way.
So like if somebody said something wrong
to John Travolta,
Samurai sword and cut their head off,
you just got clean up the body.
He just got to clean up and because it's
called,
it's called ethics protection and
responsible for dealing with it,
dealing with it.
Just leave the room and he would know
that you guys would take care of it.
Then there's also another policy,
and by the way,
the reason why I say these policies is
because I don't like when people say,
Lee,
I believe you.
I don't want you to believe me.
I want you to look it up.
I want you to look for yourself and make
your own decisions.
So I keep quoting these policies because
I want people to look it up so that they
can say,
that Shit's true.
She's not talking shit.
You know what I mean?
Um,
there's another policy called ethics
protection.
There's another policy called the
responsibility,
the responsibility of leaders,
which he actually says exactly what you
just said,
that,
uh,
basically,
you know,
what you gotta do to protect a leader.
You got to do it.
If you see a body,
then you clean it up and the leader
should never know.
I read going clear by Lawrence Wright
and I watched the HBO special on it and
um,
it's,
it's stunning,
crazy,
accurate,
crazy accurate,
and was blown away the book,
especially the book goes into great
depth about how bananas,
l,
Ron Hubbard
was right?
And it's just,
it's so odd to me that this.
All this information is out there.
Isn't out there though.
Remember,
you're reading l Ron Hubbard words from
dianetics.
Write the book one.
It says,
the first book that we're all required
to read.
Everybody's required to read everything
that he's written.
I wrote dynamics to have you sent to me.
Yeah,
I got it.
I ordered it.
It was one of those late night
infomercial things when I first moved to
La.
I've always been into a self help,
self help selling Anthony Robbins.
I bought all his tapes.
I used to listen to it on a Walkman back
in the day and read his books and I,
I,
you know,
so I thought it was just more of that
and uh,
I got put on a list and I got sent
invitations out for years,
for years.
I bet you,
I swear I'm actually willing to make
them money.
Bet that you get mail after we talk.
Hm,
interesting.
Yeah.
Well I went to one of those things where
you sit down and you get an eater and
you hold the thing and the guy asks you
questions.
Oh yeah.
San Diego.
And I was filming some.
Oh,
so you saw the say they did a
demonstration.
Did you see it read on the meter?
Like the pinch test?
Well the,
no,
I didn't,
I don't remember a pinch test,
but I do remember holding onto these
things and he would ask me some
questions,
but the guy was very uninterested or
disinterested.
He just seemed like he was kind of like
being forced to do it.
That's was just going through the
motions.
He seemed super bored.
Oh,
I wonder,
had he not been super bored?
What'd you be full on right now?
No,
no,
no.
I was,
I was doing it as a goof.
It was only like 10 years ago.
I thought it was ridiculous.
I was in San Diego filming something and
they had this setup out there outside.
I'm like,
Ooh,
let me go in there.
And I was just hoping I could weasel in
and have a seat and nobody would know
who I am.
I put on the cans and they.
No,
no,
I don't think so.
I think I didn't give a fuck.
He seen very,
you know,
a welcoming and loving because they
remember they do believe in what they're
doing.
I did.
But anyway,
what I was saying to you is the dynamics
and dynamics.
You know,
Elbert Hubbard is writing that he's a
scientist,
he's a decorated war hero,
um,
that he was a college educated and so
you're not,
you're saying the information is out
there.
What information other than what we're
reading is out there now look more like,
but no scientologists allowed to read
Lawrence Wright's book.
It's not allowed to.
So they did an excellent job of
insulating people if uh,
you and I were like friends,
friends.
Right.
And you had concern for me in St log and
you came and you said,
Leah,
I really am scared for you.
You know what I'm right.
I've read going clear and I want to know
that you're okay.
And you and Andrew's like,
I dunno if this is good thing for your
daughter,
you know,
I would say joe,
you know me,
I'm a good person.
Like I've been there for you.
You're white.
Like come on,
you know,
I don't,
I don't do drawing.
I,
you're not,
you know,
I don't steal.
I'm doing just respect the fact that
this is something I believe is helping
me.
Why would you ask me to look at
something that's anti my church or anti
what I'm doing?
Or you would approach it,
but.
And you would accept a Joe,
you'd be like,
she's right.
It is messed up of me to be telling her
these things when she is a good person
and hernia.
Angelo.
Great.
Like you wouldn't.
You wouldn't push it.
You would respect me enough because you
would know me enough to go.
Then I want to do that to her.
It's wrong.
It's disrespectful.
So you feel like that happens pretty
much across the board?
Well,
when I was outside,
yes.
Yes.
Well that's what you're trained to do.
So you're working constantly with people
that are not in the church.
Your assets.
How many people are going to come up to
you and say,
Hey,
what I think you're.
I think you're in a cult.
Well,
in your position.
Very few,
right?
Because you were wanting to stars of the
show and everyone will do that from time
to time.
Quite a few,
right?
Very few.
None.
Yeah,
none.
So when he's on a set,
is it all like he's doing mission
impossible shrimp like that?
Is it all scientology employees that are
constantly surrounding him?
Yes.
So he's got like this wall of
installation,
correct?
It's all scientology people.
Correct.
But the director,
the writer,
the producer,
they don't have to be scientologists.
Not at all.
No.
No,
but they're not.
They're not invading Tom Space.
They're not going to be disrespectful to
their lead actor.
They're not going to go up to tom and
go,
hey tom,
we,
we don't know that our affiliation with
you and what you're doing.
And the scientology thing,
you know,
they're not gonna rock the boat.
They hired him as an actor and because
of the way Tom Cruise is,
man,
I don't know,
I'm obviously,
but what I get out of him as he's just
super focused,
like very intense,
turned on intense guy and it probably
benefits him having all these servants
take care of all his every need so we
could focus directly on his thing and
just go for it.
So for him it's probably 100 percent
beneficial to be involved.
Correct.
Because it is,
it is a world that's tailor made to him
and that,
and that is,
is,
is scientology a what,
a rare position.
Yes.
It is for any human to ever find
themselves in without like being like
the conqueror of a country or something
like that right now.
Correct.
I mean,
again,
I want to make the distinction between,
you know,
listen,
when you gained some success in this
business thing,
God,
you're able to surround yourself with an
assistant and people to help you to make
your life easier so you could focus on
your work.
Um,
but this is something totally different
because behind closed doors,
uh,
you are,
acting and being a different way and you
know,
it,
I know it,
he knows it and anybody in scientology
knows it.
And that's why it is a,
it is about the mission of scientology.
So anything is justified.
So behind closed doors though,
how is he different?
It is nothing out align.
Nothing.
Um,
nothing that would upset him.
you,
you have act and be a certain
way around him.
You cannot,
um,
you just can't step out of line out of
the bounds of the policies of the church
and you or you will be dealt with and
you will be dealt with swiftly,
uh,
within your church.
And that seems to be quite abusive to
me.
I was punished for a,
basically following my own policy of my
church defending my church and I can't
be friends with somebody who you can't
be around,
that.
You can be around that and you're
getting punished by your church because
of it.
Um,
but that again,
that wasn't really even the reason why I
left.
I mean,
I was dealing with that.
I was dealing with being interrogated at
my expense.
We're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars and you've given us millions of
dollars.
Millions,
yes.
Million and now they're turning around.
You know,
they have these hate websites they
create on everybody within minutes and
inquiry and they can't really say
anything.
He didn't do anything to say a lot.
Listen,
listen,
I said to Joe,
I said it in my book.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm all those things.
Okay.
You even,
if you catch me,
you know,
in a situation or my husband,
it wouldn't change anything about what
I'm saying.
It wouldn't change a damn thing.
It doesn't matter what their intention
is to try to,
you know,
my husband sometimes sings in a salsa
club.
You don't think they're going to catch
him with a girl somewhere dancing
innocently.
You know what I'm saying?
That is yes,
you can do all those things.
You can hire Pi to follow us.
You can get us in situations.
But does that change anything trying to
discredit you?
And it doesn't matter what you're saying
is true.
Exactly.
And it's not just me.
I'm not saying it.
The other thing that bothers me is that
it's become my crusades.
Say it's not my crusade,
it's my responsibility.
And I feel other people need to step up
and take some responsibility.
I don't want to be the only one saying
it.
I don't want to be other people,
other actors,
other,
uh,
officials,
the media,
uh,
they need to not make it about me.
Get some bowls and say what you really
think.
Like I was on 20 slash 20 right with Dan
Harris and it's the parent company to a
and a and I,
I,
I did the show for somebody else and,
and Dan Harris.
I said,
what do you think of that?
Like,
what do you think of Dan?
And he said,
I have to be impartial.
And I said,
would you be impartial about abuse or
you impartial about this?
And I named a few things and he went,
well,
no.
And I said,
right,
okay,
you're being an asshole.
And you know,
the truth of the matter is,
I do think that of,
of this industry,
I think this is like a bolus industry
and there's people who have some bowls
like you,
like Adam Corolla,
you know,
there's a few people who are in the
public eye,
I'm sorry about that,
who are in the public eye,
that have had the balls to have an
opinion,
don't make it about me.
These things are screwed up.
These people's
lives are being hurt and damage and
you're in,
you're defrauding people at a millions
of dollars by your abusive policies.
You're,
you can make things confidential.
Then you say,
these policies don't exist.
Why don't you say they exist there.
You can google them and see that they
exist,
but in their defense is a magnet because
you are a famous person and so it makes
it much easier to concentrate on the
whole situation through you.
Right?
Because of the fact that you're a famous
person because of the fact that you
lived most of your life in the church.
It makes it very convenient to go
through you.
I don't necessarily think it's a bad
thing.
I guess what I'm saying,
if I say this connection as a policy.
Right,
right.
And they sit and then the next headline
is Leah Remini alleges that
disconnection.
Don't know.
I'm not alleging anything.
Look it up.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
Don't say that I'm saying it.
They're protecting themselves legally.
Probably.
That's right.
It's,
it's,
it's available for anyone to see what,
because they probably don't want to get
sued if they get sued.
It's in their policies.
Uh,
that's a good question.
And maybe they would say that they were
misinterpreting it or disconnection and
suppressives and it says exactly what
the church labels a suppressive person
that you are only your only option is to
disconnect.
So you have children disconnecting from
their own mothers and fathers.
That was one of the most disturbing
aspects of your show to see the damage
that caused and see how devastated these
parents were and family members were.
That's horrible.
That's really horrible.
And you know what people say,
you knew the policy existed right when
you were in scientology.
So why you guys so surprise?
We were taught a suppressive person is
like an evil with horns like Hitler.
You're not thinking it's my mother,
my daughter,
but when you get pulled in for something
like this,
which is what they did in the end,
they try to get me to disconnect from my
stepfather.
Then they tried to get my stepfather to
disconnect from my mother.
And so they did this whole thing with
her stepfather.
Who brought you in the first place?
No,
no.
This is another guy.
Another grandmother visit.
Yeah.
Just getting crazy.
Um,
yeah.
She's a naughty naughty,
but she's been,
she's been married to George,
my,
um,
her husband for 30 years.
So,
um,
yeah,
no,
the other guy ended up leaving us there.
He got us into scientology.
Then he took off.
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
So talk me through your return.
So you go to Florida,
you spend three fucking months getting
grilled everyday,
putting the pressure on you.
And that's been a proven tactic of
interrogations that it's always
questioned by people that really like
look at the ethical implications of
interrogation.
The problem is when you put so much
intention on
someone about a certain thing,
it makes them so uncomfortable that it
changes their perception of things to
the point where they're willing to admit
a lot of things that may or may not be
true.
Just to get the interrogation.
Well,
that's what I did.
Yeah.
I just said,
okay,
I'm sorry.
So you come back.
I come back.
I kind of like take a little bit of a
hiatus from scientology,
but I'm not creating.
Wait,
when you say take a hiatus,
you're not doing the daily thing
going in all the time.
How often are you going in then?
Um,
maybe like once every month.
Once a month instead of every day.
That's a big deal.
It was a big deal.
Then they got me back.
Then they have a big meeting with me and
they go,
we want you to come back.
We know you're upset.
Like that whole thing was just screwed
up.
Let's just come back and I wanted
specifics.
What was messed up?
I want you to tell me in writing and
then you should also refund all my money
that you spent,
that I spent having to do this.
Then they showed me a policy that there
are no refunds and if I ask for a refund
then I'm going to get declared a
suppressive person.
And so the money that you spent going
Florida and spending three months down
there,
that's what you wanted to refund.
Correct?
I want that money.
Millions that you gave to them over
because listen in in,
in a,
in their defense,
I don't think it's right to get your
money back on something that you feel
you've received,
right?
A service you've received.
Problem that I have is scientology is a
pay before you go proposition.
There are,
if not tens of thousands of people who
have money sitting on account that they
can't get because they have a refund
policy.
I can't,
I can't just call the church right now
and say I want a refund because they're
not allowed to talk to me.
So it's a catch 22.
So you're only person that you could
talk to in the church is the person who
deals with refunds,
but they can't talk to you because
you're declared an enemy to the church.
So they're holding millions and millions
of dollars of people's money that they
can't get back because no lawyer is
going to take on the Church of
Scientology for free.
But you're talking to the average guy
who has fifty thousand one hundred
thousand dollars on account.
He or she is never gonna.
See again.
So you come back,
you,
um,
you get to them,
they have this meeting with you.
You say that you want to get your money
back,
they won't give you your money back.
And then how does it go from there?
Uh,
they said,
you know,
you,
you're going to be interrogated because
you are now acting as an enemy to the
church because you were asking for your
money back.
That's a bad sign.
Then I said,
okay,
now it just kind of out opened up a
little bit of a wound.
Then I started saying where shelly,
okay,
now I want an answer where shelly is,
because I had been writing her shelly
miscavige correct,
the leader's wife and I said,
I,
it's,
it's gonna get bad for you guys because
now I started going on the Internet and
I started seeing stories of senior
executives getting beaten in the church,
like Debbie Cook and Mike Rinder and Tom
devopped and I was seeing all these
names and I was eating that they were
actually beaten,
physically beaten and for what reason?
For looking the wrong way at David
miscavige for signing,
for siding,
for rolling their eyes,
for being tired for like yawning in
front of them or something.
Yes.
So someone beats you,
right?
Or has or he has somebody beat you.
And Mike Rinder and Marty Rathbun.
We're part of that right foot.
We're part of that senior executive
strata that was up in Riverside county
where they have,
um,
a place called gold gold base and that's
where these incidents were allegedly
taking place.
Um,
so I started googling it and I started
going into the church and saying,
I'm googling this information and I want
to know why these people are saying the
same thing and the stories are over and
over again.
And then I'm seeing stories of families
being declared suppressive people,
Their Ota.
It's,
you know,
they're high up in the church and their
families are being forced.
And then you're,
then you're presented with,
um,
this is a lie.
Look Martin,
Mike,
Render admitted that he beat people and
Mardi Gras.
I said,
but that's the difference.
They're admitting it.
They are admitting that they did this
under David miscavige's direction.
You are saying that they're lying,
but they're not lying about they're
doing it,
but they're lying about having received
it.
Does that make sense to you?
Um,
you know,
over and over again,
these stories kept coming up and they
kept.
When I would ask a question,
they would put me in a room and go,
what are your crimes?
Who are you talking to?
Why you talking to enemies of your
church?
And it was just at my questions were
never answered and I said,
so does this church ever do anything
wrong?
Does this church ever do anything wrong?
Is everybody an evil asshole?
Once they leave,
is that what you're telling me?
So what would happen if you said that my
mother was.
Then I just got to believe you that my
mother is an evil person and all these
horrible things you're saying about my
mother.
I was supposed to believe you,
and the answer was don't believe me.
Believe l,
what is Ellroy?
What is elevated?
Say and then they have the policy out.
What does elevate.
You say,
read this.
Read this aloud.
What don't you understand?
What does this word mean?
What does that word mean?
Go look this up.
You haven't a misunderstood word here.
If you don't understand that anybody who
attacks your church is a criminal,
like this is the kind of thing you go
through.
So this is what you're going through
when he came back to La,
when you slowly started separating.
Yes.
Did they ever give you one of those big
gold metals like Tom Cruise?
Got.
I never got one,
but I did get a huge award for donating
another million to church.
And,
and,
and it's,
it's so crazy to me that everybody who
leaves is somebody who has an ax to
grind,
apostate,
a bigot because I've been called a
bigot.
Um,
because they,
they,
they go to the one place you can go to,
which is don't,
don't disrespect my religious beliefs,
right?
And then they can call you a bigot.
I'm for religious freedom.
Um,
for the first segment like that.
That's what they're hiding behind.
And I'm calling bullshit every celebrity
who says that shit because they know
what they're doing.
I did it too.
I did a to Joe.
So I know what they're doing and they
know that I know will just even sicker.
You're a terrible person have against
you on this.
Why?
Because you're so fiery and you,
you,
you enjoy this combat.
There's part of you that enjoys it.
Yeah.
That's what I thought about this,
when the whole thing first started going
down,
I was like,
oh,
she's a terrible person to like to leave
the church because she's going to talk
shit to the under time.
I don't mean it in a bad way if you told
me tomorrow and I,
and I really just getting to know you
today.
I,
I mean I've known you but we don't know
know each other,
but I'm really,
I kind of like you,
like,
you're cool.
Thank you.
Can you smile with your eyes?
Which is a thing that I loved about
Kevin.
Like that was the one thing I'd say
about Kevin.
Like there's like a smile,
like behind their eyes,
like there's a smile.
I always find that to be kind.
Now you could be a total dick and I
don't know about it because I don't
listen to podcasts.
Okay.
But are you a dick?
No.
Okay,
good.
Um,
because if I hear like when I leave
here,
Joe was a total fuck.
You probably hear that from one person
or two.
Okay.
But here's the thing,
if you call me tomorrow and said,
Oh,
I'm having a problem with my neighbor
because he said I'm encroaching on his
property and my kids swing set is
incredibly.
I would be.
So like I would be,
I would find every resource.
I could help you.
That is who I am.
I,
not that I'm mother Theresa.
I will get upset about I,
if I see anything on the street I'm in,
I get involved in shit.
I've always been involved in other
people's business.
Okay.
I,
if I could see into your house,
I will lie on you.
I will do.
If I go into your house,
I'm looking in your drawers on the shit.
I'm in people's business all the time.
And if I'm in a restaurant I tell Angelo
and speak to me because I want to hear
what's going on next to me.
You know?
And I figure everything out.
Right?
But,
but,
but if I see people being bullied,
if I see people being unjustly hurt,
yes I do.
I have always says.
And people who know me know that's true.
Yeah.
Well,
so this David miscavige wife situation
didn't get resolved.
I filed a missing persons report with
the LAPD.
Um,
and then I found some pictures of the
guy who was in charge of my case
speaking into scientology event on human
trafficking.
Um,
Lieutenant Dawson at the lapd police
officer being paid to speak at this
celebrity center at a human trafficking
event that celebrity center,
Scientology.
That seems a massive conflict of
interest.
Okay.
So then,
so then that's funny.
uh,
after that I called a that do all of a
sudden lieutenant to us in and I said,
so what's the deal?
Because I had given a letter with the
police report that said it was too
shelly,
if they found her,
go with this man.
Now I'm going to take care of you all.
Take care of your legal fees.
What's going on there is wrong.
You have no idea because let me tell you
said they have no telephone.
They have no mail in or out.
They are not allowed to leave the base.
If they leave that base of at Riverside
County,
they are accompanied by security or
handler.
So you think she's a prisoner?
Um,
I,
if she's alive and well.
Uh,
the second,
a best case scenario would be yes.
That she's being held prisoner,
if not by her own mind if she's alive
and well.
Right.
So you did.
What didn't she released some sort of a
statement or someone?
Someone did.
I don't know who was from to respond to
your accusations,
right?
They,
they said that they had made contact
with her and she didn't want to be
found.
I said,
did you see her or was she speeding?
Was Somebody speaking on her behalf?
Are you ready for the answer that's
classified?
This is what the police said that I
said,
are you sick?
I said,
Serosa.
You say there's something wrong with
you.
Am I doing something wrong?
I filed the report.
You know that,
right?
Like,
you know that I filed the report.
I thought maybe he was confused and he
thought he was talking to my cousin.
I said,
no.
Like I filed the report.
Of course you're going to get me the
information I need to know if you saw
her or the.
The officers that you sent there saw
her.
Did anybody give her my note?
If it did you.
Did they it?
Was she okay?
Was she.
Did you take her off the base?
Did you say?
Do you want to speak to her alone?
He said,
I can't give you any of that
information.
Could you imagine?
Then I had to spend more money,
Joe,
because this is not free.
I had to spend more money on a lawyer to
do a followup on the public information
acts.
I asked specific questions.
Who did you see?
Did you see her?
Was she alone?
Where did you see her?
What did she look like?
Didn't give me any information.
They'd go,
yeah,
you can get that information.
Who's paid to two more dollars?
Okay.
With paid the two more dollars and then
the thousands of dollars,
it costs me to get a lawyer to draft up
the letter,
so it's still ongoing.
I still don't have answers,
so she just sort of vanished.
She stopped going to events.
You stop being,
by the way,
she is called,
her official title is called Cob,
communicator,
chairman of the board communicator.
She was by his side 24 hours a day.
So imagine going from seeing somebody as
a permanent like it's not like,
oh,
sometimes your assistant works.
I'm telling you,
this is a person who worked around the
clock for him and he was his wife.
What do you think happened?
I don't know which is why I filed that.
Have you heard anything?
No.
So no one who used to be a part of the
church has contacted you?
There would be no.
Okay.
Anybody who would,
anybody who I would need to talk to me
is up behind gates in Riverside County
at this gold base.
Anybody that I would need to come out
and talk to me and give me information,
the FBI information would be behind
those gates.
Where are they getting money from now?
The scientologists because it seems
like,
well you have people like Nancy
Cartwright who give $10,000,000,
$20,000,000.
You have some whales and scientology.
Um,
you know,
you have Greta van Susteren and her
husband.
You,
oh,
big time.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's on her wikipedia page as
scientologists.
Um,
yes,
and her husband to a.
But it seems like they have a giant
staff.
They have a lot of people worked for
free baby.
Those people sign billion year contracts
and they get paid $15 a week.
No,
I'm not kidding.
I'm not contracts.
I'm not being funny.
And they get paid $15 a week and they
work from the moment they get up to
midnight.
They work astronomical hours.
These are called sea org members.
I'm not talking about average
scientologists and explain,
explain to me the car,
because was that established when l Ron
Hubbard was evading taxes?
He was on a ship.
Yes.
And He created the ship called the free
winds and whatever.
That's not called the free winds and it
is called the free winds now,
but that's where they deliver the
highest level of,
of Scientology,
their Ota,
the Ota Ruins.
But before that,
I don't know the name of his boats,
but I think it was called the Apollo.
That was a part of going clear.
That was hilarious.
When,
um,
who was it?
One of the writers are one of the Haggis
when he received like the highest level
shit that wasn't even the highest level,
which doesn't mean that was ot three.
Yeah.
And I,
and when I read it,
I literally,
you know,
you have to go into a secure room,
talk us through that.
First of all,
you have to get invited.
You have to get an invitation.
Had been scientology for years.
You'd spent a ton of money.
By the way,
most scientists,
by the way,
most scientologists don't even get to
this most,
most don't,
right?
Because you have to be wealthy to get to
this and you have to be wealthy.
But a lot of times what they do that the
new scam is you got to go.
You get to a level and they go,
we messed that up.
You have to go back down at your
expense.
You have to Redo that part.
You were talking about that on your
show.
Yeah.
So then there will be some new thing and
now David miscavige rewrites things and
says he found it in a vault somewhere
and we all believe it,
baby.
Honestly,
we all believe it because we want to
believe it.
So talk me through.
So you go through this rigor level.
Did you get to ot five?
Got Close?
Yeah.
Um,
I,
uh,
I got to sweat when.
So you to get to this advanced level.
This is called advanced levels,
right?
You are put through the ringer.
They go through every folder.
You know from the moment you walk into a
church of Scientology,
they have folders on you.
Everything you've ever said is written
down and in and videotaped.
Okay?
So they,
they,
they get your folders and they call it,
they call
it,
they go through it.
Okay.
And they go through every transgression
or you still humping your pillow.
Are you still a,
you know,
a nasty asshole to your mother?
Like they go through everything.
Are you still connected to this person
who said something bad about scientology
20 years ago?
So they make sure that you're eligible
to get the advanced data?
Where do they bring you?
Can they bring you into a room?
Where is it at?
It's at.
It's on l Ron Hubbard way in Los Angeles
and fountain.
How nervous you are you freaking out.
Finally,
all this shit I've put up with all my
life is finally going to be answered all
my questions of life.
We're going to be answered in this
moment and you realize this is the
moment you're going to get the sacred
documents.
So my mother.
Yeah.
So because I'm a celebrity,
they let my mother come in and she was
also higher level than me.
Right.
So imagine that I'm in this like double
like.
So you go through one door and the
security and then you got to get the
land.
You'd like it.
You got to get clearance,
you've got to go take a picture.
You've got to sign documents and say if
I ever reveal this,
uh,
it's going to be 100,000
dollars.
You know,
you don't ever get to read any legal
document that scientology gives you.
So you just sign things,
you know,
you just say,
sign here,
sign here.
Like today,
what you did here,
so I don't know,
I could be married to you is for all I
know when I signed today.
Um,
I liked how you shook your head.
No,
you don't need to shy.
Okay.
So you know,
comedy,
you don't deny Joe.
So I don't know why you keep denying.
That's how you step up comedy.
Another notch.
Got It.
You deny.
Oh,
I didn't get the memo.
okay.
So that's what we're doing now.
Okay,
got it.
Um,
so the,
uh,
have a secure room,
you got to land your,
take your photo you saw on the scan.
Well they give you a folder.
You have to get a briefcase that only,
you know the code to a briefcase.
So you go up to the window,
to the AOA window and you hand them your
briefcase,
they scan your briefcase and they put
the materials in the briefcase and they
close it.
They turn it back to you and you lock
it.
Then you attach the briefcase to your
body.
I'm not fucking with handcuff,
not like with a little clip like it has
to be.
Has to be physically connected to you,
so when you go pay,
you have your is coming with you.
Correct.
Okay,
so your briefcase,
they go go to the go down the hall and
use your thing and you're going to be
led into one door and then you're gonna
go into another door and then you're
going to go into the courtroom.
That's what it's called.
So you go into the three doors or two
doors,
whatever it was,
they sit down,
you open up your case and you read the
material for the first time,
the answers.
So my mother's sitting there in front of
me.
Okay.
She's so excited.
Understand that like,
this is what you want for your kids.
Like you're like,
they're getting up the bridge and
they're getting the answers to life.
So when they come back next lifetime,
they're not going to forget everything
and they're not going to be as fucked up
as they were when they were,
you know what I mean?
Like,
it's,
it's really a proud moment,
you know?
And so my mom sitting
across from me like so excited and I'm
reading this,
that my body is made up of other beings,
my body,
my whole body,
my thoughts and everything are mixed in
with these other beings that are make up
composed of my body.
Okay.
Are you following me with this?
What's your understanding of it?
Your body's made up of other beings.
Every,
every,
everything,
everything.
My thumb is composed or other beings,
your hair nails because they're acrylic.
Your skin's other banks or other banks.
Everything.
Everything like just here.
Just send,
send.
Just my thumb is as a person is being
trapped into this body.
Okay?
So I read this and the supervisor comes
over and he goes,
do you understand?
I want you to draw it out.
So the supervisor has access to this
information.
Yeah,
he's standing there to make sure.
Right?
So I go like,
this joe a person,
okay.
I go to,
there's a bunch of beings on me like
that and I give it to him like that.
And he goes,
start again.
I want you to read it again and then I
want you to draw another one.
So like,
okay,
so I did all this,
you know,
and I literally did those Joe,
I mean circles on every part of my body.
So for people drawing a stick figure and
she's drawing little circles over the
stick figure right now.
These beings were like from 75 trillion
years ago,
they were put in volcanoes and blown up
and packaged and a overlord.
And uh,
uh.
Anyway,
are you freaking out at this point?
I go,
I look at my mother who sent him.
Now the supervisors standing over me.
So I go,
what in the book wonder.
She's like,
your mom was in Ota,
right?
Your Mom's Ota.
Yeah.
Your mom's top of the food chain.
Not only is my mother is probably top of
the food chain when it comes to the
counseling side.
My mother was top of the food chain when
it came to administering scientology,
which is very rare.
She was what's considered a highly
trained auditor,
but she hadn't read this stuff.
Of course she read it.
She was just there to see my excitement.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
She was just there as a spectator to see
her daughter received the answers were
super skeptical or ra supervisor comes
over and he goes,
what don't you understand?
I go,
I understand it.
I just,
I don't,
I don't love that.
Like I'm not happy.
I go,
I just got to tell you I'm not happy
with this is what it was.
And he goes,
well,
you don't need to believe it.
You just need to do it.
So that's the answer that's given to
you.
You don't need to believe it.
You just need to do it.
So then you have to go and audit this.
You have to go and do it on yourself.
Talk to these beans on the meter by
yourself.
So,
uh,
on the meter meeting you hold the cans.
Cans,
folks,
what they looks like.
It looks like soup cans.
Like we'd drained all the soup from a
suit can and it had a string attached to
it and it's connected to some.
Yeah,
you could just google what scientology,
ie meter a meter.
Okay.
So,
so you have to hold the meter and
discuss this,
you're thinking there's just so now
you've got to go get your materials.
So after you've been checked out on this
and they get that,
you get what it is,
then you go back to the window and they
give you your actual what you're
supposed to do with this information.
So it'll say like,
it'll be a piece of paper and I'll say,
ask this question and then look at the
meter and what the answer is.
Whatever answer comes to your mind,
write it down.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So all you're doing is awakening these
things to talk to them really.
Right.
And so let them go.
You're basically saying like,
go be free,
go.
This is [inaudible].
Correct.
And by the way,
when I was a scientologist and I heard
that this was a story I was,
I didn't know.
So I would go to the Internet and go
[inaudible] three story,
but I didn't know if it was true.
So I couldn't verify it.
Do you see what I'm saying?
So most people who go,
that's bullshit because they haven't,
they don't know what they're looking at
on the Internet,
right?
There's no one to verify it with.
So if I went to my mother,
let's say before I got to this level,
they,
you're,
you're told to lie to people,
you can't tell people what the answers
are because they're going to get
pneumonia.
You get pneumonia.
Surely will die.
Okay?
So a lot of times when I lied to the
prize and then they confronted me on it
and said,
why'd you lie?
I was like,
I had to to save your life.
I mean I can only give you cancer.
So if you were about to go to ot three
and then you went online and you
investigated what is ot three?
And then you read a bunch of stuff about
these little beings in your body and
then ask your mom.
Your mom would have to lie to you.
She would lie to me as she did,
as she did.
So after you got through this,
what made you do four and five?
There's always the carrot of like,
just wait it just by the way,
here's what they do.
They set up that year,
the auditor now,
so you're,
you're auditing these things in your
body,
you're now the boss.
So they go,
they tell you,
get your hat on,
like it's your job.
You don't need to believe anything,
you just need to audit them.
So you need to do your job as an
auditor.
That's what they're called.
Auditor's people who are the ones who
take you into session and scientology,
right?
So you feel like you're in a leadership
role.
So you're doing these things a favor,
you know,
and you're like,
well,
maybe it's true.
I don't know.
I mean,
I do sometimes hear voices,
like,
you know,
you have a moment with yourself and
you're like,
I might be really kind of crazy.
Um,
so you're like,
maybe this is an answer.
It's,
it's sick because it speaks to a side of
you that wants answers about life,
you know,
and then you're like,
no,
this is some crazy shit,
man.
That wasn't even the people that know
it.
Listen,
you believe what you want to believe at
the time,
does it feel to you at the moment like
maybe if you just keep going,
fall into place,
then I'll make sense.
Like I'm confused now,
but if I contemplate this and I really
think it over,
eventually I'm going to receive enough
information.
This is all going to be like,
oh,
I was a fool.
I didn't understand.
So for example,
one time I had talked to a friend about
it,
I said,
you know,
I heard something about some genius
shit.
She pulled me into celebrity center so
fast into a secured room and she handed
me my aunt.
She said,
don't you ever say that word outside of
secured room?
I'm writing a knowledge report on you.
She said,
I'm writing.
You never say that word out loud in a
room that's not secured.
Okay.
And never seen again.
So she wrote a report on the report.
She wrote a report on me.
I got sent to what's called ethics,
which is like the Justice Department of
celebrities that have of scientology and
they said they brought me into another
secured room because they have to get
somebody who knows this information and
they said,
never ever say that would say this.
It never confirm it.
Never deny it.
Never give that information out,
ever.
That just never discuss it.
Just say I'd never heard of it.
You sound crazy.
And that's what we all say.
You sound crazy or you know,
properly done.
You get it.
You know,
like you'll get it if it's properly
done.
Those people didn't do it properly.
That's why they didn't understand that.
Do you see what I'm saying?
There's a,
there's a line that you cross.
We're like,
this is my life,
this is scientology.
That is what I believe.
And then you cross this line.
Oh my God,
this is bullshit,
right?
That,
that's uh,
that line,
that bridge that you cross and your mind
is a very distinct transition.
So what,
what was that like?
Like what is that transition like?
Like what is,
what is your life like now?
Once,
you know,
how long ago did you leave?
July will be four years.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's not long.
No,
it's really recent.
Joe,
and I'm still,
you know,
finding myself.
I'm still like,
who am I?
What do I believe,
you know,
am I some bullshit?
Am I a person that,
like you're saying,
loves a fight because I don't want that.
I don't want to be that person who loves
to fight just to fight.
I want to be on the path of,
of being righteous.
I want to be who I really am.
And,
and,
and who I really am is sometimes an
asshole Joe.
Sometimes I am,
I have a horrible temper.
I'm like,
uh,
uh.
Sometimes I feel like I'm like an old
school mafia person stuck in a female,
but I have really extreme thoughts about
life and I'm finding who I am.
I'm finding out what I really believe
because a lot of times I don't know.
I go,
do I believe in that?
Don't believe in that.
I was told that everybody smokes pot as
evil.
Do I believe that?
Everybody who cheats is evil and
horrible and just lost.
Do I believe that other religions are
lost?
Do I believe that everybody needs.
Like I Willi I'm searching.
You have to reevaluate your entire
fleet.
Everything.
And it was a big part of my day.
Remember he gave
me a mission,
gave me purpose and that's what I hear a
lot from scientologists is excellent
intelligence.
Not just hearing their pain of losing
their families and everything they've
ever known but not having purpose when
you wake up in the morning like you
know,
we have purpose joe,
we have kids,
thank God for them but this was so much
bigger.
It was for your children's children.
So giant factor for people.
Yeah.
I have some friends that were deeply
involved in the mormon religion and
they're not anymore and it was really
weird because we went to dinner once and
they were saying do you believe in a
higher power?
And I said it's entirely possible.
I said I don't,
but I don't believe in anything that I
don't have any evidence of its entirely
possible.
Like I think the universe is an
incredible mystery and I think the life
itself in consciousness is an amazing
mystery and I don't think we have all
the answers.
I don't think.
I don't think an ant can understand a
cell phone and I don't think I can
understand the universe.
I just think my brain is not evolved
enough.
I don't think our,
our,
our understanding has reached a point
where we can really accurately describe
what this is all about.
And their answer was like,
how do you get up in the morning?
I go,
I love life has I like,
I like drinking nice wine.
I like having dinner.
I like being with my friends.
I like a gel and not everybody has that.
Well they probably should find some
things that they enjoy about the life.
Exactly.
But that's the thing is finding those
things for st intelligence.
It's like a lot of my friends who didn't
really know what I was going through the
church go,
you know,
you've already kind of childish at
times,
you know,
because I never went to dinner in my
thirties and forties and had wine.
Like I wouldn't go to dinner,
have wine,
I'd get reports written on me,
you know,
we,
we had to go to church the next day.
I wasn't going out to dinner after the
king of Queens and enjoying my friends.
And if I did Joe,
I was thinking they're laws,
they need scientology,
you know,
I was never really there.
I was never really part of a,
um,
like living for the first time.
But I do have faith.
That's the one thing that I have found
and not in a weird way,
not in a,
I'm in another cult way,
not in just I had faith for the first
time.
I don't believe in any one thing.
I believe in a higher power.
And I believe that faith,
having faith is a big thing.
These people that I was friends with,
I'm still friends with this.
This conversation.
Got It.
Got a little weird that night,
but it got way weirder years later
because they wanted to believe in.
What do you mean they left the Mormon
Church?
Well,
because then they'd go,
they became untethered.
And uh,
the conversation I had with the wife was
very strange because she was like,
I grew up in,
in doctrinated,
in this fundamentalist religion.
And she goes to,
now that I'm not in it,
she goes,
I don't know what to believe.
And I realized that my mindset is kind
of fucked up because I,
I'm indoctrinated like my brain
developed
as a young age believing nonsense and
never questioning it.
She goes,
so I feel very vulnerable,
very susceptible.
She goes,
I feel like the right cult came along.
They could scoop me up.
And she was laughing about it,
but she wasn't laughing about thing on
the opposite.
Now that's why like when I,
I,
uh,
I don't want you to tell me nothing.
I don't want to be told a damn thing.
I've been told my whole life what to do
and how to think.
So I've gotten the opposite.
Just don't tell me what I need to do and
it it at the pendulum swing is far.
Do you have any.
Let me go into the DMV when they go,
you need to stand there.
I don't need to stand anywhere.
Like I don't need.
Guess what?
I don't need my license renewed and then
I'm that person.
I want to destroy my whole day and get a
ticket because I don't want to be told
what to do.
He doesn't talk to me.
Like,
um,
you know your child and don't talk to me
like,
you know,
I'm very much that way.
You know,
you should have shorter now.
I don't give a shit what you think about
my nails.
I want them that they're slightly longer
than average because it's purposeful and
when I don't want them anymore I won't
have them.
But that's just a small scale.
But I don't want people telling me what
I should think anymore and let me find
my way.
I'm going to make mistakes.
I,
but I want to find my own way.
Sort of reestablishing your own personal
sovereign.
I don't know what it is,
Joel.
And like I said,
I'm going to Piss some people off,
I'm sure,
and I'm going to make a lot of mistakes.
I'm going to not be the perfect person.
People think I am or want me to be,
but I got to make mistakes.
That's how you learn.
I wasn't able to learn.
It was like,
do it this way,
this the way we do it.
We don't do this,
we don't do that.
I mean,
I was always a little bit of a rebel in,
but I thought everybody was being held
to this higher standard.
They weren't.
I was finding out other celebrities was
smoking pot and then going into the
sauna.
Yeah,
exactly.
Doing their purification.
Run down 100 times because that's when
that's in the beginning steps of
scientology.
You have to do what's called a
purification rundown.
It's supposed to a detox your body of
all you know,
nothing's.
You're not there yet.
No,
you don't get that.
I don't get to say on baby until you get
there.
Oh.
When do you get there?
What?
You have to spend $380,000
and about 40 years of your life.
Forty,
yeah,
that's a lot of work.
Still work.
Um,
no,
you,
you learn a,
basically a purification rundown is
just,
you're supposed to sweat out all of the
toxins lodged in your fatty tissue.
Now the problem with that is,
um,
you taking large amounts of value sin
and they claim you're,
you're,
you're running out like a Suntan from,
from when you're a kid and from other
lifetimes.
And it's yes,
Flash,
nice and hot and yes,
and you have to sit in the sauna for
five hours of dance,
a five hour thing.
But I was finding out,
I was like,
wait a minute,
why was that prison?
He was smoking pot to smoke pot,
right?
Like,
I haven't been smoking pot this whole
time,
you know,
where people do and I'm learning that
other people were smoking pot,
doing other drugs and then going in the
store.
And I was like,
wait,
I didn't know that was an option for me.
Like I was living by this,
you know what I mean?
So that's what I'm going through now.
I'm not saying I'm smoking pot,
but somebody want to a little bit only
because I want to be calmer,
but it might not make it all adds to.
Okay,
that I don't want it.
Could I have a different effect on every
tool for that shit?
No.
You're definitely not John Old.
No,
you're not.
you're alive.
If you're alive,
you can experience the benefits of a
consciousness enhancing substance,
whether it's mushrooms or pot or any
job.
That's crazy.
It's not crazy.
I don't know.
I look at me.
I'm like,
are you freaking out?
We'd been in a cult.
You're whole life.
Sorry folks.
Nobody insights.
All other than the people are going to
tag me in.
You
are listening to this.
Well,
even the people that are going to attack
you and me,
I don't feel bad for them.
I feel bad for them.
I feel bad for anybody that wants to
attack anybody for their beliefs or for
talking about stuff,
and guess what?
If your religion or your belief system,
it's so easily destroyed that someone
can have a disparaging opinion about it
and it that threatens you to the point
where you want to attack that person.
You're doing something wrong,
you're leading your life wrong,
you're on the wrong path.
There's a lot of people that have
different opinions about a lot of
different things and it's one of the
more interesting things about life,
right?
Like you don't like coconut water.
I fucking love coconut water and we're
allowed to you,
don't you?
You like Cologne.
I think it smells like shit.
We're allowed to have different
opinions.
This is one of the beautiful things
about life and people like different
kinds of music,
different styles of art.
They like different kinds of houses in
different landscapes.
It's,
it's one of the things that makes people
interesting.
Right?
So the problem with any kind of
ideology,
the,
the problem with what,
what this represents or any other kind
of cult or any other kind of really
rigid structure is that it's human
beings are very susceptible to those
kinds of routines are very susceptible
to influence.
We're very susceptible to other people
carving out is predetermined patterns of
behavior that you just quickly slot into
because it keeps you from having to form
your own opinions.
Right,
and that's,
that's everything that's wrong when you
truly believe that you believe it.
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
And you do.
You do.
I mean it's very easy for people to just
slot themselves into these patterns and
adopt those opinions as their own
instead of trying to formulate their own
because it's very complicated to try to
formulate your own opinions and they
have to be flexible because new
information comes up and then you have
to kind of change them and adjust them
and then recognize that perhaps you like
you're recognizing right now that like,
wow,
I've like kind of like I've lived a lie
for like a long period of time.
I mean,
it doesn't discredit you as a human.
It doesn't.
I mean,
and it's very brave of you to discuss
that because it
gives people that are listening to this
the same sort of understanding of these
thoughts that are in their own mind,
whether it's because of whatever
religion.
Fill in the blank and that's the other
thing about this.
How the fuck did they have tax exempt
status because they,
first of all the irs,
the answered the irs questions to get
that status and one of them is you have
any affiliation with any other God of
which they said no,
they deal with you.
They,
they,
they believe that they are spiritual
beings and they deal with the spirit.
Um,
and so they answered the questions that
needed to be answered for the irs.
But it's amazing that any religion gets
ca tax exempt status.
All of them are ridiculous.
Well,
I don't want to make a comment about
other like bonafide religions because I
don't like some of our bonafide.
Yes,
I do.
I gonna tell you why.
I mean honestly,
Joe,
you have to really make the distinction
between an organization that takes your
mind hostage from the minute you walk in
and that you are,
you are required to be there 22 and a
half hours a day that your eternity is
at stake.
That the planet,
every man,
woman,
and child on this planet,
they're lives are at stake with what we
do in scientology.
So using the pen fundamentalist
Christians.
You said fundamentalists.
Okay.
So I'm not talking about that.
What I'm talking about are what,
what I witnessed as a child with my
grandmother.
My grandma lived down the street from
her church.
We would walk in on the way to get,
you know,
sausage and meatballs and things she
needed to make her sauce and she'd go in
and light a candle for her friend Connie
or she'd go in and light a candle
because I lost my ring.
Or She'd pray to this scene or that
scene.
And when I was scared at night she would
say,
pray to this person,
pray to you know,
do your cross and God's going to protect
you when you sleep.
And here's your angel and you know,
here's your little car.
She would give me little,
um,
you know,
the saints on the,
on the necklaces and stuff.
And she'd say,
and I believed for that night that that
scene was protecting me or that God was
protecting me.
And and those comfort,
it gave me comfort and so that's what I
tell my daughter.
I don't want you to believe in anything.
Although I did baptize,
baptize her as a Catholic,
I said,
I want you to really find your way with
some kind of spirituality,
but I'm going to baptize you to Catholic
because I feel you need some kind of
foundation,
but I don't want you to be forced to
believe in anything,
but I want you to believe in something
or you're going to fall for anything.
And I didn't have structure as a child.
I had scientology.
And by instructure right.
Well I mean a real,
a real religious base.
That religious base.
Correct.
That's never heard.
The difference between a cult and a
religion is a beautiful quote.
What is it called?
Bullshit.
It was created by one person.
That person knows it's bullshit in a
religion.
That guy's dead.
Why did you come up with it?
No,
no,
no.
It's just something I read.
Yeah.
I like it,
but it's true.
So I,
I would.
So that was my experience with religion.
No,
I know people feel very differently
about religion being forced down their
throat,
but I would have kind of loved,
you know,
going with my family every Sunday to
church.
I think it,
it created a,
when I saw my father doing that with his
other daughters,
I was a little bit jealous that we
didn't have that right.
But we didn't get Easter dresses and it
wasn't a big thing because my,
you know,
we didn't have that growing comfort,
right?
Yes.
So that's also the,
the um,
I'm trying to look.
It doesn't cost a quarter of a million
dollars,
you know,
to get up to this level that I explained
to you.
And by the end of it,
if you have made millions that you're
going to give those millions away,
um,
it is a requirement that's on a
requirement and in other religions that
you are not allowed to talk to certain
people that now I understand that there
are other calls that do that.
And I,
and I do call those things a comb
because I don't think any organization,
any church would tell people who they
can and cannot talk to what they can and
cannot read what they should and
shouldn't do.
The person should make their own
decisions based on the information
that's given to them or information that
they find on their own.
Right.
It's very different.
This is a pay before you go proposition.
There are repercussions to leaving.
Nobody knows that.
I went in and out of the Catholic church
the other day and lit a candle.
It was calling me saying,
where are you?
Why you not here?
Who you talking to?
You need to come in or we're going to
start working on your family,
destroying your family.
Do you
does understand what you're saying.
But you know,
there's,
there's different styles of behavior
patterns that exist in all sorts of
religions.
Like Buddhism is radically different
than Islam,
you know,
and there's different requirements that
they ask of the people.
And a lot of it is based on the
environment that these religions were
established.
10,
based on how long these things have gone
on for whether or not the,
uh,
the people that are a part of that
religion have gone through the
enlightenment,
like what,
what different factors played apart and
what standards they uphold today and
what make people.
But my issue is always with subscribing
to predetermine patterns of behavior and
ideologies.
Where were they indoctrinate you on
specific ways to think.
And that's what this is.
Yeah.
That's what a lot of religions are.
I mean,
it's,
it's a real issue with,
with human beings.
Well,
my grandmother,
of course was,
was yes,
exactly where he used to think a certain
way about people or a lifestyle
and a,
but she had the choice to be friends
with somebody who maybe wasn't those
things.
Right.
Choice.
We don't have a choice.
No,
it's,
it's pretty obvious that some,
especially in particular,
the way you are describing scientology,
it's far more suppressive than most and
far more rigid in its behavior patterns.
Right?
And they forced you into these behavior
patterns and it's,
it's incredibly difficult to break
behavior patterns,
especially when you believe firmly in
your heart that this is the right way to
be.
Yeah.
Ben's justified because you're clearing
the planet.
It's just amazing that they don't have
to pay taxes.
That's stunning if you look at their
doctrine,
if you will.
But that's the thing,
the word where there have been judges
that should have looked into the doctor
and they said it's not,
we can,
we cannot actually look into the
doctrine.
Um,
but they need to understand that there
are.
You need to look into the doctrine where
it's abusive and hurting people.
If your doctrine calls for you to hurt
people,
hurt children,
uh,
the government does need to step in.
You're right.
Yeah,
I agree.
Well,
it just absolutely this,
the accusations about the sea org and
about people making 15 bucks a week and
about these people that are essentially
working as indentured servants,
that's not legal.
They sign up for it.
So as long as you sign up for it and
sign that billion dollar contract,
you're not subject to any minimum wage
laws or anything along those lines.
Yup.
At men,
by the way,
Joel,
not really that smart enough to speak on
these things because people think that
my,
that my agenda is to take away their tax
exempt status.
Uh,
I would love for that to happen,
but that's not the reason for the show.
They're just want to express yourself
and be honest about your experiences and
help other people experience free.
These are other people's experiences
too.
But because I know it's true because I
experienced it,
I'm cleaning and I'm saying,
you know,
if you're going to bully somebody,
bully me,
bully a and a,
but I'm going to let these people tell
their stories because they're telling
the truth.
Right?
Yeah.
And if we weren't telling the truth,
you would have sued us.
So cut the shit already.
Well,
that's what's interesting.
Is that the disclaimer at the end of
your episode,
our episode,
it's in 100 times.
Yeah.
It's bullshit.
But they got to do it.
I understand.
Smart.
It's smart to do it,
you know,
to me it's annoying.
Every time I see it,
I roll my eyes.
I mean,
every time I see it,
I understand it,
but you know,
it's,
it,
it's annoying because what we're saying
is true.
Again,
this is a litigious group.
Okay?
They're not going to shy away from many
lawsuits if they could have sued us or
they would have,
but they know what we're saying is true.
These are the policies of the church.
Here's the thing,
Joe,
what they should do is go,
yeah,
we subscribe to these policies.
You don't fucking like it.
Don't be part of our church,
but don't say we're all aligning.
It's right there on the Internet.
You assholes.
I had the books at my freaking garage.
What are you learning about?
Not Owning at all?
I felt like you were.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just thinking now your,
your,
your current state right now,
like doing this show and uh,
having all these people.
I feel like you're helping a lot of them
for sure.
Because you're,
you're,
you're getting their message out there.
And again,
it's a very heartbreaking message when
you see these people and they are not in
contact with their children and they're
not in contact with loved ones.
It's an imagine
daughter doing those videos going.
My mother just wants to make a buck my.
I'm disgusted by my mother and she
discussed that.
She,
that she's my mother.
I would be crazy.
I know.
It's crazy.
I'm,
I'm one of the lucky ones,
you know,
like these things didn't happen to me.
Joe.
I wasn't mad.
I wasn't molested,
I wasn't hurt.
I wasn't physically hurt.
I wasn't.
My kids didn't disconnect from me.
My Mother didn't disconnect from me.
I have my mother during the holidays.
I have my sisters,
I have my husband now.
Your life must have revolved around the
church and a very big way.
Socially.
Yeah.
What is that like now?
Like all those people they've written
you off,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
it's sad.
I'm sad for them because our
relationship was,
was obviously I'm dependent on my
relationship to the Church of
Scientology.
So you can understand that right from
them being brainwashed and.
No,
because they knew me.
Right.
So from my church to say,
you're lea is an enemy of our church.
My friend should have said bullshit,
but aren't you kind of an enemy of them
now though?
Uh,
I don't know why I would be.
They know we're telling the truth.
Right?
But that truth is very damaging to their
organization because the organization of
the church,
right?
You're right.
No,
I'm not saying anything wrong behind it.
Say you don't like it.
Don't be part of it.
Yeah,
but they can't really do that.
Why?
Because they're doing some fucked up
things.
Maybe
they say they're the epitome of morality
there.
The,
the,
the elite of mankind there.
Saving the planet.
So when you go on their website and see
that,
they say they are the largest growing
religion.
They own the only ones.
What?
The solution to life demands.
Ils.
I'm not making this up.
Okay?
So when you make those kinds of claims,
you
good?
Then stand behind it.
Say,
that's right.
That's right.
I don't believe in other things.
We don't.
We think you're all lost.
We are extremist.
We are bigots and we.
This is what,
these are our beliefs.
Then don't join us.
We obviously have enough money.
Do you communicate with any of the
people weren't allowed to talk to me.
In fact,
I've seen celebrities who talk shit to
me on twitter and social media.
Not directly at me
and they run from me.
They run from me at parties
and they're lucky.
They're lucky that they run because
honestly I don't mind.
I don't mind you talking shit.
Just when you see me back it up.
That's all.
Just back it up.
Can you say,
I don't want any.
I want to know why I don't want to name
a name Joe.
Yes,
because I don't want to give him that
much
credit.
I don't want to give them that.
You can just name any,
any celebrity that you know
like that does a scientologist.
We would.
We have.
We have Kirstie.
The alley.
We have Tom Cruise too.
He's still in.
Why she me a bigot?
Yeah,
because you don't like scientology.
Right.
But I wasn't a big hit when I didn't
like anybody else.
What site intelligence.
Right.
Because that's what I was very much a
Vegan and she knows it because she is.
She's deep friend Danny masterson.
I'm Laura Pre pon.
He was on the 70 show.
Oh yeah,
she's in Laura preponderance.
I'm Juliette Lewis,
her brother,
light field.
Like Bill Lewis was just at a wedding,
her Juliette Lewis,
his brother who I grew up with.
Light field.
Okay.
In the sane,
intelligent community.
He was filming a wedding.
He was a sinner,
like,
you know,
doing the video.
He literally ran from me and my husband
and he was videoing the wedding.
So whatever that shot was.
And my husband even said to him like,
he said,
hey,
he goes,
life hill.
And he ran.
And the other band members because
angels singing,
right?
Uh,
he said,
is he okay?
Is He?
And he's like,
oh,
he's a scientologist.
I'm ignorant as to how many celebrities
are scientologist.
I don't know.
That's a weird one.
Why?
Well,
because he's a musician,
you know,
and he's like a uber creative.
You would think that person is like
super open mind that he comes out with a
song like,
I'm a loser baby.
So why don't you kill me that song.
So this song,
I'm a loser.
That's him.
Yeah,
that's him.
I love that.
So it's back.
It's like a big hit for sure.
One hundred percent.
Okay.
And then this one's saying yes,
I had to leave him because he seemed to.
Ish.
Yeah.
Like he would be a nine inch nails.
That's Jamie.
He wears yeezys or look at them,
gave me an Indian.
Who else is in deep?
Jenna Elfman,
right?
Janet,
are you still in deep,
deep.
Whatever happened to her.
A child,
that big show,
I don't know.
We all go up and down in her career is,
you know,
that's the thing too is like,
I love how the church tries to measure
like she's a uh,
an actress,
a past her time.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I'm selling my website.
How's anyone pass their time?
If you're still alive and acting right.
I mean he was famous,
but I was,
I was famous enough when I was in.
Right now you're past your time.
That's what they're saying about you.
Oh,
Hillary,
that's adorable.
By the way,
are you can't measure pw,
,
w we have an up and down career.
That's,
but,
but I,
I don't,
I don't need to work.
I want to work.
I love what I do.
I love acting.
I love making people laugh,
but I don't need to do it.
Right.
You only need one solid hint in your
life.
You know that um,
this is my passion.
This is something that I always wanted
to do as far as helping people.
This is why I in scientology.
I loved helping people.
It was everything to me.
If somebody needed help,
I was there.
I just love it.
That's why I know like to talk shit
about these people I know in their
hearts they really believe they're
helping even attacking me is helpful.
So I don't really want to call these
people out like this specific per but,
but at least have the balls to back it
up when you see me.
So you believed they had just have
misguided intentions but their
intentions are correct as you did at one
point in time to.
So you're uniquely qualified.
Call anybody a liar,
a bigot.
I would tell the [inaudible] story is a
lie.
It's crazy.
You sound crazy.
What is the story?
This is the story.
This is how they got to be attached to
our bodies.
The new story is they got package.
What is it?
You can google it all into a volcano
that got dropped into a volcano or
something like that.
Yes.
They got packet like there was at planet
that existed like this.
It looked like this and then the,
the,
the Lord Xenu thought that there was too
many people on the planet.
So we packaged all these people up.
Is that Ota stuff?
No,
I think this is stuff.
Steps two,
three.
And then what?
What happens?
Like at Ota,
your mom's out now,
right?
Yeah.
So hold on.
So
you were told when the very beginning
and scientology that you have a reactive
mind and so in dianetics you are running
out these bad experiences that you've
had maybe this lifetime,
maybe last lifetime,
maybe lifetimes ago.
So you're,
you're told that you have a reactive
mind and we're going to take it away.
We're going to find it and we're going
to take it away.
So you don't even know that you have it
until you're told you have it.
Right.
So you run all these things,
these incidents,
like you'll get it
picture in your head.
Oh,
I'm getting a picture of that.
I was like a French medieval times,
whatever.
They're like,
that's okay.
You don't have to believe it.
Just say it.
Just say what it is.
Yes.
And then I was burned at the stake.
I was a,
which I obviously I was in Salem and I
was worried because I have a problem
with fire,
you know,
and you're making up these things as you
go and then you're like,
I think I'm making these up.
And then there's a policy that says the
person's going to say by on harbor that
they're making it up,
but they're not making it up.
These are real pictures of real past
lives,
I don't know.
Right.
Okay.
By the time you get to Ota,
you're told,
okay,
so what wasn't true?
All of that was a law.
You made that up.
But what is like,
what aren't you?
So I'm not a,
I'm not a body,
I'm not a
arm.
I'm not a this,
I'm not.
I was never louis the.
I was never that guy that I said I was
never a witch in Salem.
I was never.
So That's what Ota.
So you're basically told what?
What wasn't true?
What are you like,
what are you really?
I'm just me.
Is the answer.
How did your mom get out?
My mom got off that ship and she said,
I'm never going back.
Why is that killing another thing?
Because you thought it was bullshit,
but thought it was okay
when you were going through your ot
three thing and they're explaining to
you that you're covered with bugs that
are beings.
You're not,
not.
We need to go back.
Maybe I'm laughing,
joking around a little beings that bugs
or without a body.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
so your mom got all the way past that
and something she decided at one point
in time.
It's bullshit.
It wasn't for me.
What was it that she decided?
She didn't tell me that she would have
told me that that would have stopped me
from going.
They would have pulled me in a meeting.
When did she think it was bullshit and
she got to the top.
She can't tell me.
She thinks it's bullshit.
I'm still coming up behind her.
If I.
If she then pulled me in and said,
Leah,
this is bullshit.
I don't want you to continue.
Then I would have turned her in.
I would have.
It would have.
They would have gone to work on me and
your mother.
You need to disconnect from your mother.
She didn't want me to disconnect from
her is her family.
So you learned to be quiet.
It's so complicated.
It is complicated and it takes years and
years of this.
You don't just.
It doesn't happen overnight.
So your mom got to Ota so she had to go
to the ship.
Yeah.
And is it the wackiest to the wacky.
When she got there and she's like,
this is nonsense.
I'm done.
We're just happy to be done.
Finally,
it was almost like she was free.
Wow.
Yeah.
So what happens when she left?
Did they go,
hey,
where are you going after you're done?
They let you off the ship,
right?
You complete it,
you get a cert and that's it.
You don't have to go every day anymore.
No,
and now created more ot levels now.
So she would have been called back in.
They created more like what we just went
into the vault,
uncovered a squirrel.
We found some writings of l Ron Hubbard
before he passed and I swear to God,
it's not even a lie and you believe it.
Joe,
don't laugh at me because I feel bad for
like,
I feel bad for the people looking back.
I go,
you know,
we were all went into it like with a
good heart.
Like we believed what they were saying.
It was like,
well,
what do you mean?
You just found it.
Element Hubbard said it was the end of
the bridge was Ota and we spent her
whole life doing this.
Like you want there to be a definite
end,
you know,
so I can live your life a little bit.
It's just incredible that a science
fiction writer could create something
like this that's so poorly written and
we only knew of his science fiction
writing,
like from him telling us,
but it wasn't like we were faint,
new l Ron Hubbard as a science fiction
writer.
It must be in some knowledge of it.
Otherwise battlefield earth would have
been made.
Of course they have a whole building on,
on,
uh,
they have a whole literary building on
Hollywood boulevard called Arthur
services and it's all dedicated to
Elbert Hubbard's publishing.
And you walk in,
you think this man is a serious,
right?
Like,
this is somebody who was really.
Well,
people don't know.
He wrote more books and wrote more stuff
than more fiction than any human being
that's ever lived ever.
Is that true?
Yes.
He wrote more fiction than anyone who
has ever walked the face of the planet.
Something about his.
He made up,
made up more shit than anyone who ever
lived.
So he wrote down more shit.
That never really happened.
Then anyone who ever lived,
but the scientology stuff he was telling
the truth about.
Right.
But you don't make that,
you don't think that,
you know what I'm saying?
You don't make that distinction.
You don't,
you're,
you're reading dianetics because it's
self help book.
Like you were searching for something
bigger.
You know,
most people are looking for that.
And so when you read that book and
you're like,
Oh,
I could cure myself a psychosomatic ils.
And um,
big part going clear is that it,
it,
it seems pretty obvious that he was
going through some issues himself and
he's trying to self diagnose and self
himself of blindness.
He said,
so,
and you believe it.
You want to believe it,
Joe,
you want to believe like I can cure
myself of things.
I am the cause of my own,
um,
wellbeing by my own thoughts and I don't
want this reactive mind.
And,
and,
you know,
that makes sense,
right?
When people say,
have you ever done anything that a,
is uncontrollable to you,
that you know is damaging to you?
And you're like,
yeah,
every day I don't want to make bad
decisions.
Well,
that's because it's your reactive mind.
It's beneath you.
It's,
it's,
it's in your subconscious.
Deep in your subconscious and we're
gonna help you find those areas and
we're gonna help you to stop making bad
decisions and who doesn't want that and
you believe it.
You know,
you go from maybe you know,
punching somebody in the face,
you know,
for looking at you a certain way to
being able to control your emotions.
You're like,
oh,
okay,
maybe this is working.
Oh,
okay.
I used to do drugs.
Now I don't,
you know,
encourage these cases,
saved her life.
So she believes that it saved your life.
It saved your life.
I'm not taking that away from her.
I'm not taking away your gains and your
wins,
but don't take away the fact that you
know I'm telling the truth and don't
come from me when you know I'm telling
the truth because then we do have a
fucking problem.
That's okay.
It seems like,
yeah,
there are a clan you know and you are
opposing the clan.
They know it's true.
I have a listen.
If you didn't know it was true,
then I'd be like,
oh,
she's done aware.
She knows it's true.
So to come from me,
it's kind of crazy.
It is kind of crazy,
right?
Like what?
What is the predominant criticism
amongst these people?
They're not.
They can't say you're lying,
right?
Uh,
yes.
They say,
I'm lying baby.
Not just me.
We're all lying.
Any person who's spoken out against the
church is lying.
We are bigots.
We are invalidating their religious
beliefs.
We are.
I'm telling them that something didn't
help them.
We're not.
Nobody's saying that.
Nobody's said,
if you feel you've been helped,
you've been held however you know the
truth and now you have a responsibility.
But what they think is,
I don't want to have a problem.
Scientology helps me.
And so that's all I care about.
So you don't give a shit about abuses.
You don't care that children were being
molested and these things were being
hidden.
You don't care that were being molested.
Honey,
if you even just google that,
what I just said,
scientology and Traumas,
you will come upon website after website
of,
of people saying,
I was molested while I was in the church
and the church did nothing about it.
I'm not alleging it.
This is what I've read,
this is what I've seen,
right?
Um,
and I've been in.
I hadn't heard that.
Okay,
well,
you're going to,
you,
you can hear it.
You're going to hear it because people
are becoming more and more vocal about
what's happened to them.
And so if I seem overly passionate about
this subject,
it's because I have heard these stories
over and over again behind the scenes.
I have heard stories of people being
abused,
children being abused mentally,
physically,
sexually,
and I'm only me with a show,
you know,
a,
and he can't do anything other than just
let me tell these stories,
right?
Um,
so,
um,
virtually,
and,
and Mike Rinder and other avenues that
we,
we really can't talk about.
I'm trying to do something right by
these people.
And so the last thing that I want to be
bothered with his bullshit from a
celebrity who knows that,
um,
we're telling the truth about what we
have already spoken about,
but to be interested enough to maybe
find out what I am talking about now.
Right?
The granite one is really odd because
she's a newsperson.
She's supposed to be a television news
journalists,
right?
I mean,
isn't that what she does?
Um,
yes.
But why,
what,
why is that?
Because I would just assume like you
would want your news from someone who
doesn't believe a bunch of wacky shit.
Well that I'm in her defense.
I mean,
who,
who knows what I need a person believes
true.
Um,
however,
the distinction that I'm glad you did
make is when you are hearing about
abuses,
when you were hearing about things that
are happening that are hurting people,
you then do need to say,
I'm aligned with this organization.
And so I do need to find out how long
has she been in it?
I think most of her life.
There's a lot of people like that,
right?
You get indoctrinated as a child.
Have you received emails or any sort of
contact from people who your show
benefited and it,
it was the catalyst for them leaving
a lot?
No.
For leaving.
Have A.
we've received tons of emails of people
who said,
I'm glad you told me that.
I'm glad I watched your show.
I am well informed now.
I will never step into a church of
scientology.
Um,
what about people leaving because you're
not getting some intelligence watching
the show,
right?
You know,
they have shows,
right?
They have to be on the front.
Well,
average scientologists do,
but they're not watching shows like
this.
They'd have to pay for that.
Literally,
Joe,
like you'd have to go in the next day
and pay to have your own interrogation
and punishment handed to you for
watching a show like ours.
We're going clear after awhile.
You just go,
I don't want the punishment.
Especially if you believe that I am the
devil.
If you believe that I'm a liar,
that I have crossed over to another side
that I'm not to be listened to.
Why would you support somebody who was
talking shit about you and your faith or
your family and people you love?
Would you out of your way to listen to
them maybe,
but the average person doesn't want to
seek out things that they think are
damaging.
What kind of blowback have you received
from this and what kind of blowback
back?
Because a guy like Paul Haggis are
Lawrence Wright or of,
well,
Paul had to watch his family go on his
website that the Church of scientology
created and watch his family talk about
him disconnect because they're still in
disconnect from him as every single
person who's been on this show,
um,
they've been followed.
They'd been harassed,
they'd been,
they pi is following them.
They have people showing up at their
jobs.
They're getting mail of like people who
are,
people who don't even have never stepped
into a church or getting mail connected
to me,
mail at their house,
like have never stepped into a church of
scientology.
The girl does my eyebrows.
She's like,
I don't know.
I said,
you,
you'd never substitute.
She said,
never.
She's getting mail for the first time
for the Church of Scientology.
It's just crazy.
But that,
that,
that's just a little anecdote but that,
but to have your family make videos of
you,
to not talk to you,
to refuse to see you,
you're their own grandchildren.
Um,
that,
that's just something I can't deal with.
But also now what we're,
what I'm dealing with now is hearing
stories of these people who have been
silenced for years,
the pain that they've,
they've had to deal with and sustain
through these years effect that they're
normal in any way is a miracle.
Um,
and so I hope to do something with them
and I hope to make some changes.
What,
what are the positive aspects of
scientology and how do you think it
benefited you and do you think it's
possible to take some of those positive
aspects and either reform that
organization or form another
organization that doesn't try to control
people's thinking but maybe positive,
maybe tries to encourage the positive
benefits of being a part of a group,
promote anything good about it.
Because I know it's an Olin proposition,
right?
But isn't it?
But isn't there some,
Hey ben read books.
You can buy the books if you want to buy
the books.
But I,
I mean,
I don't think there's,
I,
you know,
go into a therapist now when I bring up
concepts and she's like,
Oh yeah,
that was in psychology.
Psych one.
I'm like,
what does that.
A lot of it is from this existed,
so yeah,
but I,
I believe in,
in,
uh,
I'm finding things that work for you.
I don't think it's one thing.
The one thing that my therapist me is
that it's not just one thing,
you know,
you get something from here,
you get something from there.
It's knowledge is scientology is not
about knowledges.
It's about us
in this therapy thing is very new to
you.
You never went through any.
My first thing that I said to her is,
I just want you to know that I think I
know more than you.
I was taught,
I was taught as a sign
intelligence that you are,
you have wasted your life going to
college.
Uh,
I could do for a person and five minutes
on this emitter what you're going to do
with me in it,
you know,
in five years.
Like,
what did your therapist say?
I understand,
I understand.
I understand that you feel that way.
And she said,
uh,
you know,
that um,
spirituality and religion should have
nothing to do with the ego.
Would like that stayed with me for a
second because I was like,
I have a huge ego.
She's right.
Scientologists believe that they have
the answers and when you believe that
you have shut yourself off to a.
The fruits of our observation to
experiencing other people,
to opening your heart up to things.
I mean it's.
It shuts you off completely.
So you feel like this is a part of you
that you're really exploring or
exploring maybe for the first time.
Non Cologne thing is like,
I'm so judgy about it,
but I'm willing to maybe change my mind.
My Non Cologne thing.
I'm sure you've seen that video of Tom
Cruise,
the where it's got the mission
impossible sort of soundtrack playing in
the background.
He's talking about a car accident.
Have you stumbled upon a car accident?
Like you know that you were the one of
us take care of it because you're a
scientologist.
You're the only one that can handle that
and and you believe that when you're
assigned,
told you you are not only you are taught
that we are the only ones doing anything
that you are.
The only ones,
that's why it was so shocking to me when
no one in my church is willing to stand
with me.
I was like,
wow,
so we are not those people who stand up
right where we are,
the people who look the other way
because you're all looking the other way
because the time,
because of David Miscavige,
because you have no balls really,
are we those people?
Because the truth of the matter is when
there was an accident,
Joe,
I did stop.
I am.
That person has stopped since then.
That's one of the positive benefits of
scientology.
Well,
you feel that you're responsible for
everything and you felt like you wanted
help as well.
Oh,
we felt he could help and you wanted to
help.
That's a positive thing,
right?
Right.
And also intelligence.
Do you think they're healthy?
Right.
So there's gotta be some.
Like one of the things that I've found
about a lot of scientologists ego,
so if you think you're the only one
doing anything,
by the way,
there are other people who stopped,
but I believe in my heart I believed
that it was because I was a
scientologist that I stopped,
but then I saw in life I was like,
wait a minute.
There's good people in the world.
They have no interest,
no ulterior motive,
no vested interest in helping somebody
right there do like.
I'm more shocked like what the show.
That's why like in in the last episode,
I was in tears.
I was a mess because I was shocked by
the goodness of people that I thought
the world was so screwed because of
scientology because I thought we were
the only good people in the world.
Do you see what I'm saying?
I so,
so stupid and juvenile.
It doesn't though.
It completely makes sense and honestly
from someone who's lived their entire
life indoctrinated in that I ideology
and you've only been out for four years,
you're.
You're showing a remarkable amount of
self insight and a remarkable amount of
ability to examine the flaws of your
past thinking and current and current.
Yeah,
because everyday I'm like,
that's really messed up.
But to abandon the foundation that
you've kind of established your entire
life on,
it's got to be insanely difficult.
And to do it in your forties after all
these years of being involved in this
crazy sort of organization,
it's very,
it's very admirable.
It's very hard.
It would be way easier for you to just
keep,
stay in,
stay inside your comfort zone,
keep doing all your nonsense,
get up to 55 or whatever the fuck it is
now,
you know,
and just a key.
Paying the money and keep your friends
right now.
Do you miss any of your friends that
were in it?
Um,
no.
I only miss,
um,
the children have,
like my goddaughter and you know,
because I see her,
she lives in my neighborhood and she
can't talk to you.
Well her mother can't talk to me.
She doesn't know me now.
I delivered her,
you know,
deliver the hospital and then I moved.
We moved my friend close to me down the
street so she could be in a certain
school district and then I'd be able to
be my goddaughter and a,
I see her in the neighborhood and she
can't talk to me.
So the,
the,
you know,
that my car door doesn't know me.
She wouldn't know to come to me because
she's now only,
you know,
five,
six,
you know what I'm saying?
Um,
how were they hanging on?
How do they,
how do they stand a mess?
$3,000,000,000
in assets.
Three billion.
Yes.
And so it takes,
it's gonna take a few good men and women
to stand up with us and,
and,
and get interested.
You know,
like I said,
there's been a few public figures to,
to publicly come out.
You're now one of them.
Conan is another one.
And,
and you know,
Bill Maher,
like there's some people with some balls
that are willing to say this is
bullshit.
We should be doing something about it.
The world at large is supportive of,
of me and the people who are
contributing to the show.
Amazingly supportive.
Social media has been amazing to us,
um,
and,
and as well and eat very brave to do a
show like this at first time of it's
kind,
I mean a series about it.
Um,
it took some bowls and their part,
they pussied out with disclaimers but
okay.
I think they probably had to do that for
you don't need to defend them.
Um,
so I think more and more people are
coming out and more and more people are
being supportive,
but we need more people in the public
eye to say this isn't enough.
We need to do something.
What has it been like doing press for
this and promoting it?
Like what have been the varied reactions
from people that you've talked to?
It's,
I've been varied.
It's been very supportive and beyond.
Touched by it.
Like I didn't know what I was going to
get.
I didn't know if I was going to get
people who were gonna,
you know,
kind of walk the line and go,
well,
I don't know.
You know,
the one problem I had was with them
because I felt,
you know,
Dan knew enough.
Dan was provided with enough.
We've talked to him enough,
Dan Harris,
you know,
from 20 years isn't like cut out.
I was like,
we can't be impartial about things.
We shouldn't be impartial about like,
come on.
There's things in the world you need to
stand up to.
Right?
And I want people to feel that power,
whether it's this cold or other cults or
I'm a political party or agenda.
Like I feel people have the power to do
something.
I think that's becoming more and more
evident and I think people need to start
standing up for what they believe in.
They can do something and we get asked
that all the time.
Like what can I do?
I say,
call your congressman,
call them and say,
I want you to look into this.
I want you to do something about this.
If you're a lawyer who could do
something,
you should contact us.
If you're somebody who has a knowledge
of something that that could,
could help us prosecute you need to come
forward.
Because a lot of the stories that we
told the statute of limitations on these
abuses have already passed and it's
their words against,
you know,
a hundred others,
like let's say,
uh,
we walked in right now to that base that
I was telling you about.
Most of them wouldn't leave.
They don't know what's going on out
here,
baby.
They don't know that what's they're
being told is not happening.
You know what I mean?
So,
uh,
I would love to do that.
I'd love to walk into those gates with
the FBI and say,
Hey,
you all who want to come with me,
come with me now and we're going to take
care of you.
Um,
and I've asked Mike Rinder that many
times.
Like I said,
they probably,
they won't go with you.
I'll stand there and say,
what are you talking about?
You know,
you've been beaten.
I beat you,
you beat me.
He beat,
you know,
people were saying,
well,
yes,
he,
he had to rub some people up and he
admits it in the show.
But not you,
you didn't beat anybody.
You have to smack anybody around me.
And in general,
because I did shit,
I haven't been into a few fights and
clubs.
You've been in fights in clubs,
but you don't drink?
Well I did drink joe.
You did bad while you were in,
in the group and you got lit up and
crack some people.
Yeah.
But that's because I'm from Brooklyn.
Um,
I blame.
I blamed Brooklyn,
blame Brooklyn.
That's strange.
I don't blame anybody but myself and my
bad attitude.
But did they ever make you smack anybody
or anything like that?
No,
it's not about snacking.
It's about.
But he had to do that,
right?
He had a beat people.
David miscavige and this is what they
have said.
And they said it under oath.
I'm David miscavige under his direction
has,
um,
and they,
and they had admitted to that.
Um,
but were they admitted it?
They'd be 20 people who said they're
lying.
And I was just like a punishment thing,
whether they're flogging these people or
it's like a,
they had a policy called overboarding
when the ship was,
um,
where the sea org and they went
overboard.
Somebody who was out of lunch throw them
Correct.
And so now you tossed them in the water,
right?
And so now you don't have overboarding
because you don't have ship.
Right.
But when you say them the water,
they pull them back out or fuck you.
I'm sure they throw him a line.
I'm sure you know.
Yes,
they got back on the boat but it was a
form of punishment and now they've just
assimilated that to be like,
we don't have a boat so it might as well
crack him in the mouth or break his
fingers.
You don't have a boat anymore?
No.
Well they had the free winds but they
don't have a seaward ship like they used
to.
Now they have bases,
you know,
celebrity center.
I don't know.
Celebrity Center.
They have been mentioned that a big
factor like what happened to the boat?
Why are you obsessed with the boat?
Because like would be a cool thing to
own on the old cytology boat going
parties?
No,
this is.
This is where they told the people about
ot search right in here.
Okay.
Do you remember what I said?
There was the Apollo.
Okay.
Joe,
do we need to.
It was a boat.
That's what started this called the
Apollo.
Where they give Ota is called the
freelance.
They still have that boat.
The boat's still around that both still
around.
So you can buy that book probably in the
Bahamas.
Oh,
that's where they go.
It's a good place to party and learn
about the fountains and it's not
partying.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
No partying at all.
No,
but when they do have a party,
because they have a big old celebration,
like I saw the one celebration,
I would go to the gala every,
every year and yet the celebrity center.
And what,
uh,
what happens there?
A with listening to speeches about how
much scientology is accepted in the
community by the lapd and talks lapd a
bunch of money to the parents.
Yes.
They give,
they give.
They started a thing called the police
activities fund a leak.
Sorry.
The police at night and I contributed to
it and I helped it and they put on a
show for the kids every Christmas at
celebrity center and they give them
money.
The proceeds to what they created,
which is called the police activities
league.
And they
present the,
the only pd with money for children.
Well,
it sounds great.
It's great,
but it's,
listen,
it's purposeful.
There's a policy called safe pointing,
uh,
the community and that's what they're
doing.
And I did it.
So I know what it's about.
Right?
You appear as if your intentions are
pure so that you then have maybe favors
like this happening where somebody files
a police report and you get screwed
with.
Where do you think this is going?
Where do you,
where do you anticipate your ballet?
I don't have a battle.
I hope that we kind of do.
Um,
no because I,
Joe,
if you received the calls that I
receive,
like when,
when I'm not working on the show because
you know,
I'm an executive producer of the show so
they're not safe to just call anybody.
Then I'm going to call and it's my,
me and Mike.
It's were the ones who have to vet these
stories and kind of a,
people trust us because they know we're
telling the truth and they know that we
have their best interest at heart and
telling the story correctly.
And when you talked to these people,
when I talked to them behind the scenes,
it takes every piece of me not to break
down.
I have to be kind of a their auditor,
you know what I mean?
There's scientology auditor to keep my
shit together.
But when I hang up on devastated by it,
I'm devastated by it.
Like,
Oh,
I've been part of this thing.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm getting teary eyed talking
about now many people are in it,
maybe 10,000
worldwide.
Well it gives the appearance because I
thought like at these big events to the
shrine auditorium that they have every
year,
right?
They show what scientology is doing and
they use things like hundreds of
millions and these really kind of
electrifying statistics.
Right?
And we bought this building when we
bought that building and that would
indicate growth.
Right.
That's the subliminal message to you.
You know,
there's people in there,
but there are just buildings and.
But you believe that those buildings are
being.
Well they have to do for tax purposes.
Right.
And the appearance that it's growing,
but it's.
But they have to get offload some of
this money.
Do you have an endgame with all this?
My end game is just to tell these
people's stories to validate that their
pain is real.
I'm not going to let the church bully
them or scientology bully them into
believing that they made it up,
that they're out to get money or fame.
You don't make money doing this show.
I'm not saying how long are you doing it
for like,
I don't know.
I really.
How many episodes have you done?
We've only done eight and then two
specials.
You know,
like some,
you know,
the reddit specials that we've done,
but you know,
there's a whole other,
there's a lot of stories to be told.
I didn't even scratch the surface.
So how many stores are we going to tell?
I don't know.
What's my end game?
My end game is that these stories get
out there,
that people get incensed enough where
this church,
well I have to call him your church.
This organization is held responsible
for the things that they have done.
And um,
they stop destroying families.
I mean,
there's so many tiers to it that I
don't,
I don't know where it ends,
but somebody,
no plan as far as I know
going to stop hurting people.
That's it.
You're going to stay.
You're going to take some responsibility
for what you've done.
These stories are real.
These are not liars.
People don't say they were hurt and
molested.
They don't go on television for fame to
it.
They don't get money from doing that.
Now,
who wants to go on television and say,
uh,
I was coerced into getting an abortion
and,
and who,
who,
who does that for fame?
Really,
Joe,
I was hit.
I was abused.
I was sexually molested.
I allowed this to happen.
These things are not easy for people to
admit to.
Right?
You know,
you think it's easy for me to say I was,
you know,
I believed in this my whole life that my
mother believed in it her whole life,
that my stuff we gave our life to this
thing.
Well,
you're very fortunate.
Your mother made it out to God.
I've been here a little time and I'm
sweating.
No,
that's okay.
We'll,
we'll wrap this up but didn't know how I
feel about sweat.
Like I can't even wait to get the shirt
off.
They don't sweat.
Well it depends.
I mean if it.
Well I do like sweat but I don't like it
when I'm dressed.
Okay.
All right.
You like make it sweat into
congratulations on that with.
No,
I think.
I think you're very brave and I think
what you're doing not just didn't.
It's like what you're doing with your
show,
but the way you're admitting your own
personal demons and the battles that
you're having with your own mind trying
to sort of reformulate your view of the
world and figure out who you are.
Thank you.
Know.
I think it's very important,
very important for people to hear.
Thank you baby.
And honestly,
I really thank you for having me because
I,
it's,
it doesn't come without some
repercussions to you,
I'm sure,
but I want you to know that I appreciate
it.
I really do
listen,
my pleasure.
And,
uh,
let's,
say hi again and not,
not over some wackiness like this after
all these years.
It's been funny.
I haven't seen you in so long.
The seven minutes before we started
this,
we had a very funny color.
It was very funny.
No,
seriously.
What would you talk about another year?
What?
I for sure know.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
But I think there's something there.
I don't know if there's something funny
about what we were talking about it.
Nobody's going to say what was it?
What was it?
What was it about smells and things.
Oh,
it smells and things.
Periods.
Goodnight everybody.
Leah Remini show when is not.
Well,
it's done now.
Yeah.
But what,
uh,
oh,
I think you see it online and it went
well.
It's on a and e all the time,
but on where they show it constantly.
It was on just a couple of nights ago.
I said,
I'm so glad.
Yeah,
they're,
they're hearing the shit out of it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
uh,
if people want to follow any of this,
is there a website they can go to?
I think they can go to eight.
Look,
God,
I should've.
They'll find it.
Google it.
Google it,
folks.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Bye everybody.